okay are you live
okay we're on time
council newton's just joining your chair
right just let him
give him a minute to get in there is
councillor orkins in
[Music]
okay good morning everybody uh and
everybody who's watching on youtube
uh this is on s internal and
my name is pete watson i'm the chair um
we'll go to our agenda apologist for ab
absence son are you doing this sandra or
mary
no i'm doing the meeting chair okay
as far as i wear there are no apologies
but counselor hawkins is subbing for
council
councillor cough lunken oh sorry yes
yes richard's in now nice point to come
richard late
yes okay
okay minutes of the last meeting pages
four to ten
chair you've muted yourself
right okay
okay page four page five
[Music]
page six page seven
page eight space nine
and face ten could i have a proposal
please please
simon i'm newton second
who was that
was it you joe that's me yeah
right sandra could you do the honors
please
yes thank you chair councillor watson
four councillor haynes
or councillor bowton
at four hensler hawkins
i'll abstain on that one thanks thank
you
counselor gab
or pencil online food for
counselor manly or
ancelerinch oh abstain i wasn't there
uh counselor newton or
four thank you
now before we go on to item three which
is public contributions
i would like to propose that we
we move this to item number seven
so that the callings can follow the the
the the public contributions
could i have a proposal and a seconder
for that
i'll propose it
yeah second that i'm happy to second
that's chairman
yeah and council aims second it we need
to take the vote i think we do
you do chair but chair just to say you
proposed it so you only
need a second hour we've got a second
there
yeah you proposed it though already so
you just just needed a second oh and
then go to the vote
yeah i've got too much too much on my
mind with this agenda
okay so we just need to go to a vote
thank you chair councillor watson
for councillor james
or chancellor benton
for councillor hawkins
s4 councillor gab
for counselor langford
or manley
or councillor inch for
and councillor newton four
[Music]
we didn't do the minutes either but i'm
four on the minutes as well
apologies that was my
vote uh mr den gate for the minutes
was for mr harper for the minutes
i'm four but i also want to raise an
issue on the minutes please
okay okay ian
raise your issue page five
matters arising once again the pids
document that we're using at the moment
have not been circulated
it's about the third time of asking
i don't know where you are ian on page
five
page five matters are rising minute 57
it says pit document will be circulated
okay
i think it's on the action list as well
when we get to it it
i think it is on the action list isn't
it
okay yes it's on page 12 for the action
list
minute 59 um although
uh mr harbor is right they haven't been
been circulated
and there's a response from adrian on
the action list and it is still a piece
of work yet
yet to be completed okay
fine chair yes
what i'm asking for is the ones we're
actually using at the moment not the new
ones we're going to work on
hmm
where is where are you in i can't see
you
i'm here is your video not on
it's the way we only come on when we're
speaking
all right okay
right so do you want to answer that
steve
okay yes yes mr harper is right um
i'll speak to sean and adrian we'll make
sure they're completed before
uncirculated before the next committee
meeting okay
that's fine okay right we'll move on
then to
to the action list which is on page 12.
yeah can i yes sorry can i just take the
votes for mr dane getting mr harper
um the uh change in the order of
the agenda yes of course you can are
they
i think they've both agreed actually no
four oh
thank you chair okay right
actionless well obviously
we've got minute 69 which is
still ongoing um
minute 53 hr comes update to provide
on the meeting that's on our meeting
today
minute 53 update
that's on the meeting minute 55
treasury investments that's completed
minute 59 uh response from major
projects and he states with
that's ongoing minute 59 matches are
rising
that's completed public
minute 61 public contributions
and that that's ongoing minute 66
uh forward plan is completed
okay anybody got anything to say on that
before we move on
nope okay
[Applause]
declarations of interest um
all the com all the committee members
understand about the declarations of
interest so
i won't bore you with that anymore um
agent mattis brought forward back with
with the mission of the chair well i
ever got no
um urgent matters um
agreement of agenda parts one and two
well we've got no part two
so now we'll go on to
public contributions
okay
right i think our first speaker is
tristan good
uh speaking on the apple door ship
slipway
and
tristan you've got three minutes
unmute yourself i think
is that better that's fine carry on
three minutes
yeah firstly i would like to take this
opportunity
to say thank you for allowing me to be
part of this meeting my name is mr
tristan gabb
and i'm a regular user of the apple door
slipway and i have been for many years
i've only three minutes so i'm going to
keep this as short as possible but
straight to the point
number one accusations so far regarding
only jet skiers no real evidence photos
can be very very misleading
and surely videos of apparent misuses
misbehaving
would be classed as real evidence and as
videos are so easy to record
why wasn't this done number two
people have been using the slipway at
churchfield car parks for many decades
and as of the case for those people they
have gained the right to use that
slipway
number three educating users
at our club appledore pwc club have been
educating
users of all types and warning the one
or two misuses of the water of great
results in the last year
and we will continue to do so in the
future
also please can we have permission
to supply and install signs clearly
showing the rules at appledore
number three accusations of parking
issues
aimed clearly just towards jet skiers
where
are all the photos of the many boat
goers that use the patched area
in the same manner and there are a lot
more boat owners compared to jet skiers
other parking issues in the car park
surely have been solved by torch
district council and the great efforts
in controlling the motor home
motorhomes in the car park which
should free up a lot of spaces
may i take this opportunity to add this
motion not only affects jet skiers but
also boat users as both
share the same boating laws may i also
confirm with everyone here today
that jet skis do not chase birds away or
do we not chase dolphins out of the
estuary
or do we kill seagrass these are just to
name a few accusations that i've seen
and heard recently
sent in from friends and family from
from a local councillor
finally more to the point the safety
issues i see
is a regular slipway user and a user of
other slipways throughout the southwest
it's unbelievable that appledoor is the
only slipway which still entertains
swimming crabbing fishing etc
in the slipway area which is designed
solely for watercraft
use only as far as i'm led to believe
other slipways apply a 25 to 50 meter
ban
in that area for all public near that
slipway
oh and one more thing i would just like
to quickly add
as a member of a public please can we
put a stop to the ongoing personal
harassment
pointless pictures being hand delivered
to my company's accountants
i am unsure why my company has been
brought into all of this
and and this is a personal matter and
not a business matter
and i hope this can stop pretty soon i
thank you once again for the time
and that's that's all i have to say
today thank you
okay thank you tristan thank you very
much
okay our next speaker is
darren sperry
hello hang on darren
i'll tell you when you can start now
good morning uh thank you for the
opportunity electrician and like tristan
i'm a regular user
of the outdoor slipway and have been for
around about 35
years now of one way or another
um i'd just like to start by saying that
um
i would like to read a statement that
was from north durham gazette which was
given by councillor ford where he said
he wasn't being a killjoy and there were
some alternative locations that jet skis
could be launched from
but that someone was going to be injured
or a loss of life unless the safety
concerns were addressed
i cannot see how the bandit of the
launch of jet skis from april slipway
addresses the safety concerns
jet skis will be able to launch from
bank end uh possibly from lymer's lane
possibly from crow
probably to vinsto so how is that going
to address the safety issues within the
river
if there are you know of any subjects or
watercraft
um so another statement
that the seagate hotel has spent a huge
amount of money on major refurbishments
over the years
uh agreed um and he mentions that how
would you like your sleep being
disruptive so are we talking about
safety issues of the river
are we talking about the potential loss
of revenue from local establishments you
know
i think we need to be clear there of
what the actual agenda is is here
is it the safety or is it the loss of
revenue
may 2013 torres district council were
asked a question
following the uh unfortunate death in
padstow
caused by speedboats the question of
what was asked of them was what action
would turretis accounts will take to
prevent the high speed and dangerous
practices of jet skis
and speed boats close to other water
users on moorings in the estuary at
churchfield
the response that was issued again this
was on the 22nd of may 2013 the estuary
as a whole is a voluntary
set of rules also produced through the
torrent torch s3 forum and coast and
countryside service such as the areas
for speed boats water skiing jet skis
and volatile speed limit in places too
any safety issues need to be addressed
to the marina coast guard agency
jet skis well subject to noise
complaints are less dangerous than
propeller driven craft since they do not
have an exposed propeller to injure
people in the water
as they are powered by a water jet that
is torres district council's response
to the question that was given to him
now let's get down to the the six not
speed limit obviously the code of
conduct which is we don't learn from
toronto's website
everybody knows it's a six knot but what
is not clear is where
is that where does it start where does
it finish
if you launch rapidly slipway and you're
heading out to the jet skiing
area which is airy point where
do you are you allowed to actually go
past the six knot speed limit
is there any indication is there a boy
you know it doesn't show it on the code
of conduct i'm looking at
oh wind up darren please all right last
thing
is that jet skis are being obviously
ridiculed in this way but from what i
can see down there
is there no craft a boy a base a six
knot speed limit
insta yacht club you know when they're
sailing are they the six knot speed
limit within yestery
no i think not so i i think jet skis are
being
unfairly single date thank you okay
lauren
thanks very much right next
speaker we've got is owen atkinson
if you're there
good morning oh right okay uh yeah i
just had to unwrap
i'm using a second three minutes from
now then are we
uh good good morning councillors thank
you for the opportunity to speak at this
meeting hopefully some of you have got a
copy of the draft letter i sent
in via email earlier on to summarize
i've been owning and operating vessels
uh within
the outdoor area for over 40 years
currently operating a commercial fishing
boat
over this time the increased traffic on
the asteroid
has been tremendous due to the fact of
the lowering of the costs
not only of jet skis but other water
users such as kayakers
on this issue of closing the slipway off
i've got no objections to any process
using
the hardware as appledore is a free
harbour and as such everybody within the
district has a right to use the waters
they're in
there's been previous comments made
around about the speed limit
again this is a voluntary speed limit
and the only official speed limit starts
at flagstaff bottom of lyman's lane
and the rest is on the voluntary code of
conduct
there are currently 13 businesses that
operate
using apple door slip way and with
reference to the seagate hotel
saying about losing night's sleep the
owner should then consider
as outrageous if you buy a business
that is adjacent to a public right away
in this case the waters
and on a commercial port they should
expect some noise no matter what time of
day or night as
we cannot justify the times of the tide
i wish we could but we can't
so the noise issue to me is for the
seagate hotel
is is nonsecond they bought a property
adjacent to a waterfront um i say
there's 13 businesses used in the
slipway but not only that
the many recreational people that come
into the area
tourism brings uh revenue into the
council through parking charges within
the car park to put a ball out and to
stop this
is nonsecond in my things when you're
every counselor i think in the land
is looking for funds to to block
to raising funds is is ridiculous in my
own opinion
by blocking the slitway you do not no
matter what water user uses the estuary
take away the underlying issue
of people that are in the minority the
very few that spoil it for the very many
that use the water
you'll only displace it as darren
clearly said most
or either the water or the personal
watercraft users
go to sea wood and they do not go up the
ashrae if you block off the slipway
at apple door you're only moving the
problem further upriver and potentially
exacerbating the issue
by the jet skis or other water users
traveling further distances potentially
can you start to wind up there
owen please so what i would like to put
to the committee is
you need to look at the bigger issues as
how many
people actually physically use it from
gig clubs
holding um regattas through to kayakers
and other water users not just singling
at
one particular type of water user so
therefore
i would like to see that hopefully the
committee will take on all the comments
used today
for today and then put in to revoke the
idea of blocking
the slipway at churchills thank you very
much for your time
thanks our next speaker is
um oh david chalmers the mayor of
northam
are you are you in david yes sir how are
you
yeah yeah okay go then three minutes all
right
thank you good morning um and thank you
very much for giving me this opportunity
to speak to you um i've been asked and
instructed by
my town council northam following our
meeting on the 24th of february to come
to you today
um and you will have already received a
letter from uh from the town clerk
sort of expressing the views of the town
council
we had a very good and informative
debate on this issue
and uh overwhelmingly we
wanted to express our
opposition to the bollards being put in
place and
to the banning of jet skis going from
the slipway
you've heard eloquently from some of the
other speakers this morning on on
some of those reasons why and what i
would urge you to do
is that this this whole issue needs to
be looked at
much more sort of holistically um we
don't
uh dispute that there might be concerns
over safety
um the use of the water but we also know
that whilst we're needing to protect our
residents
there are also a number of issues to be
looked at as well um there's businesses
that use the slipway for instance and
also
the the number of businesses who are
dependent upon
visitors and tourists coming to our town
i have been really proud that our
might the towns in northern ecuador
westwood hope northern
have during the pandemic managed to keep
this balance
of protecting our residents whilst at
the same time
sending out a very warm welcoming uh
message to visitors because so many
businesses are dependent upon um
the sort of the either the recreational
views or the business use
of the water so
many issues we feel that the banning of
jet skills as mentioned is unfair
it's singling out one sort of particular
use we don't dispute
that there needs to be better signage
perhaps people have put forward an idea
of a warden
volunteers other ideas of how we can
actually look at this i don't
i'm not asking today for a solution to
the problem
but i think what torridge district
council needs to do is to look at this
issue holistically and really examine
the facts
and look at what answers we could come
to this
someone else has said this morning um
banning the the
the use of the slip way is just moving
the the problem
somewhere else and won't actually defer
the uh the danger of some of the the
vessels on the water as well so then
this needs to be looked at
much more holistically examined properly
and we would urge you to do so and it
would have the full support
of northern town council in doing so
um yes that's that's basically what i
wanted to say this morning
okay thanks very much david thank you
okay
we uh we now get onto the
one of the main events before that i
would ask can i can i just bring stacey
in
to give us the legal uh the legal side
of it please
as what we can do and what we can't do
yeah thank you chair happy
happy to explain um
the situation today so this is a calling
of the
community and resources decision that
was made on the
1st of february so community and
resources resolved
the closure of apple door slip way for
jet skis with suitable bullets being
positioned to enable continued access
for swimmers
and canoeists and the decision for bank
end to be left for the harbour board
to be agreed um so effectively when one
of our committees
makes a decision and the council publish
a
decision notice um and within a five-day
period
that decision can be called in um
by the ons committee um
so it's the chairman of ons uh three
members of ons
or four members of torridge district
council so
on this occasion um four of our members
have called
this decision in for ons to review
um so owen s can review the decision
if they remain concerned about that
decision
they can refer it back to our cnr
committee uh for reconsideration
um setting out the nature of their
concerns
um and our community and resources
committee
um will hear the matter again and
consider it
now if there's uh a dispute between
ons or a difference in opinion between
ons
and cnr then that ultimate decision will
be referred
back to our full council um for them to
ultimately decide so um the
only options available today if
um ons are concerned about the decision
that was made with cnr
is to refer it back to community and
resources for them to reconsider the
matter
but they need to make recommendations as
to why they believe it should be
reconsidered
okay it's very much stacey um
okay we'll just move on before we go on
to the actual
um looking into it
um i would just like to to go through
the counselors that who
have called it in i'll start with
counselor mcguff
um could you just uh tell the tell the
committee
what and and the public why you actually
called your tim
councillor thank you very much mr
chairman um
do we have this present on the the item
list here
because it was printed is imprint for
everybody to read
yeah well i'd just like to where you
tell me what what it is yeah
well again if you just put up as well
please remember to publish to read it as
well in case everyone's hard of hearing
they can read it as well please mr
chairman
but i will then carry on for you i sit
in a community
resources meeting as you're well aware
i'm the vice chairman of the community
resources
i caught this decision in because of the
lack of information of a
rough a rough weather slip launch slit
for your apple or a lifeboat
now this was in the report at cnr
now there's a few things missing a
report on cdnr one would be actually
true facts were missing so we based our
decision what was in front of us and
i believe we made the wrong decision i
stand by that that's why i called it in
um now it's some substantiated claims
about the health and safety issues
on the river we have no proof from janet
williams team
of torrence that there's any safety
issues with river at all
now common sense going forward is the
unfortunate
situation of a minority of people
spawning for a majority
and the implementation of ebola system
going
would then penalize residents and
visitors alike who are going to visit
epidural given the lifting of the
current pandemic
now this is very important obviously for
epidural and
the uh the jet ski club awarded the pwc
club
have actually offered to update the
signage free of charge
at torres district council they've
offered to go into a
permit scheme but as we all know once it
goes to the river
we can't enforce anything and neither
can the police i've never seen a police
vote in all the time i lived here
so we do have an issue going forward now
i think the common sense thing would be
from the public speakers all the public
speakers vote very well
and i think the main thing going forward
is the education
of the users of the slipway they're not
to penalize any residents
thank you mr chairman was that enough
that's enough i'd just like to ask you
one more question
so why did you vote for it then let's
see or not
thank you very much mr chairman like i
just said to you i voted for cnr
because the way the meeting went at cnr
was the only facts that we had and we
had unfortunately we had some damage
report from cancer
let's deal with some facts okay
i should be able to come back i'll do it
no
don't let this break out into a
free-for-all
just deal with facts don't you'll be
absolutely
all in good time i just want to know
councilman goff why you voted for this
record
at cnr that's all i'm asking
am i late to answer it of course you
know what
thank you much every time i see a good
answer i get him interjected
we voted on the information that we were
given and we weren't given the factual
information
there you go mr chairman okay fine okay
okay we'll move on um okay
next counselor shelly shelley what why
did you
want to call it him
um well my name actually wasn't on the
list as of one of the people who called
it in
although i did call it in but my name
isn't on the
paperwork that came out so i'm quite
happy to speak
but um do you want me to speak on that
basis just give us the reason
cheerleader
okay okay uh right well i pulled it in
because
um uh having sat
in and watched the meeting um i was
persuaded that jet skis um
were um or could be conceived of being
an
issue um and i can come back to that
later if necessary
but at this point i'll just say but i
did not think i understand completely
why bollards were suggested
but i did not think that any sort of
barrier was the answer
because of the effect that it would have
on access for a lot of people
and at this point that's that's all i'll
say thank you very much okay
okay chairman can i can i just mention
um
in terms of council langford's uh name
being emitted from oh yeah
yeah yeah um
should have been on there for for
whatever one reason or another
um it was missed and that's why um that
the chairs raised it at this point and
uh sean was going to pick that up at
some point to say
your name should have been uh in the
report but unfortunately it wasn't just
that's our mistake so we're very sorry
don't worry um okay
if councillor jones here no he's not
present chair
right okay counselor newton
where are you simon i'm here
what what can you give a short version
actually
why you wanted to call again yeah
specific to why i uh asked for this to
be called in
uh i was led to believe that
the slip is a rough water
launch site for the rnli
and the placing of a bollard could
impede the operations of this emergency
service
i stand corrected i don't know factually
whether that is but i have been
told and informed that it is a rough
water launch site
and i understand that that material fact
was not considered by cnr when making
this decision
secondly uh i have a view
that um in a location like apple door
on the waterfront in a key tourist area
we should be opening up not closing down
we're in order to encourage people to to
come
and use our facilities and i will talk
about that more
later but those are the two reasons that
i call it in
okay thank you simon uh
councillor pennington did did you join
this
[Applause]
yes i'm here chair yeah did did you join
this
i've joined you yes do you want me to
speak
chatter yeah just just just a short
version phillip i don't want i don't
want war and peace he started
i'm not for the packet i'm full of
pennington okay chair thank you very
much indeed
um yeah um my reasons are there i'm glad
that
shirley langford put her point in
because i wanted to raise the issue i
actually called it in
as my role as chair of overwatch gaming
on a single calling
um it reads in your minutes here that
it's three conservatives and it was
been pointed out to me it looked like it
was a political calling and having
shirley's name being missed
it put the balance right to to make sure
that it was
across all parties it was coming through
i was
hoping that we would put on our forward
plan
looking at issues around torridge torres
is absolutely important to our
environment
um a lot of things happen on torridge we
need a wider perspective and i
felt listening to the meeting when i
attended on the first of february
very simply we didn't do enough duty
to look at what issues are facing
torridge and i would have
i was hoping to put onto the forward
plan environmental issues for toronto
yesterday unfortunately our last
external when s
they decided as a committee against my
proposal
um to put that on the forward plan so
i'm a little bit of
a miss how it goes for at the moment but
i think this is a wider torridge
discussion
and that's why i called it in okay thank
you phillip
right we'll get down to down to the to
the bones of it now
who wants to start
chair councillor haynes has raised his
hand yeah i'm just putting on the
participants
thing okay peter oh thank you chair
yeah um yeah the council full council
voted
to to stop jet skis after a debate
about the concerns um the jet skis
not just on the church field slip but
out in the water
and it was felt the only way to deal
with the problem
was by some by a ban and bollards
um since then there's been a lot of
feedback from the public
and a lot of important issues have been
raised
um to do with the practicality of
bollards
and sort of talking about alternatives
like a warden system etc
um i mean i think we should entertain
these other ideas and and talk further
about the bollards
um i feel that we haven't really had
enough information from officers
as to how the bollards would work um
we've heard about some sort of um
key system or code system and then we've
heard about problems to do the lifeboat
etc
um we've had input about well what about
a warden system
um we haven't had really any information
from officers about
how that might work and what the cost
would be we haven't had any costings
really at all about feasibility of all
that
um we've had wardens before i understand
or a warden
but the jet ski problems being you know
has been going on for years
i we need some sort of input about you
know how effective was the warning
system really
um and we were just generally more
information
i think i don't feel we've got enough to
go on at the moment
thank you yeah to be fair peter um
um i and i will bring sean sean kay in
here in a minute
they didn't really have that much time
to sort out how a bollard system could
work
because this kind of got called in
yeah one day or two days after the
decision
so uh i i'm led to believe
that sean sean kaye actually
did contact the the lifeboat people
and said if we put and said if we put
bollards up up there or a gate
with a lock on it they would be they
would be given a key and they were quite
happy
could could you just come in and clarify
all that sean
thank you chair yeah yeah i didn't
contact the the lifeboat
crew they contacted me chair just oh
sorry no that's fine
um we we haven't devised a system
because obviously
the decision is still under scrutiny so
um the issue that was considered at
community resources was a ban
on jet skis and it's very very difficult
to
enforce a ban on something with some
sort of control and they would
undoubtedly be
if not um a ban on other users there
would undoubtedly be some disruption
for other users um if if all odds if
there were physical
impedement for people to get down to the
slipway so yeah that those details
aren't yet available because we haven't
yet designed the scheme
that we would introduce hi thanks sean
i thought that was the the situation
okay with another speaker
tony tony inch thank you chairman
i hope you can hear me uh yeah i i've
i've been uh looking at this since uh
and i
i watched the youtube um debate on this
when it came up to cnr
may i just remind the general public
that are listening here
that cnr stands for community and
resources
and you know i've been thinking about
this a lot because when i became a
coaster some seventeen and a half years
ago
somebody asked me what i was what i was
why would i want to become a counselor
and
my answer was to work with the community
for the good of the community and
courage
and i think i still think that
that is my job as a coacher and
in this case i don't think we're doing
this
and and singling out jet skis in my mind
is absolutely wrong because uh
how can you do that in a in a in
a community where we should be serving
everyone
you just can't ban one thing and i think
that
it ought to go back to cnr now
and if i may uh mr chairman
i'd like to make a suggestion or a
recommendation
or a recommendation that cnr
goes back to cnr uh considers
reinstating the water
and that they or torridge engage with
all users
of the slipway so that we can
find a way forward so the slipway can be
used safely
and also in that to look at
income generation at the slipway
and i think that uh is all mr chairman i
think that
okay if i have a seconder
i think i'd like to put that forward
thank you
yeah uh jude
thank you good morning um yeah i would
like to second
councillor inches proposal i also
um very much against bollards not
against jet skis i think you're just
somebody's just fit
you know pointing their finger at one
particular thing that's out on that
river
if there was uh talk of them being moved
to bank end
they get moved to ban ken they can go
anywhere from bank end
they can go through apple door and
there's no rules
and laws where they can go um so yeah i
would
definitely like the second councillor
inches proposal thank you
okay thank you very much thanks jude
um who else have we got this ah
count a little later thank you chair
well i was waiting to hear from
committee
members before i chipped in but
i couldn't believe that that decision by
cnr
i thought it was a terrible knee-jerk
reaction
uh and just to put the matter straight
as councillor haim said
full council recommended banning nor
they haven't full council haven't
recommended banning jet skis
they just recommended that councillor
ford's notice of motion went to see an
offer discussion
it's clear from what has been said it
was it it was an ill-informed and a very
brief
discussion at cnr because councillor
laws at our meeting at northern town
council the other night said
he'd made a mistake in supporting this
now what i would what i would and i
would i'm on the same wavelength as
councillor inch
and councillor gob we need to reinstate
down there
the uh slipway warden stroke car park
attendant with a little
hop there that he used to have there
should be a nominal charge made for
anybody launching down that slipway and
i mean
a nominal charge and not only the issue
with
um bolts on the water jet skis on the
water
if you have somebody there monitoring it
certainly through the summer months
they'll pay for themselves they'll
easily pay for themselves down there
the other issue that was raised was
parking on the hatchway area and the
turning
area for the bus on the car park now if
you've got an attendant there
they would monitor all that they would
also monitor
any boat users jet skis or anybody else
speed bulbs
off off the breakwater there at
apple door once they've gone down river
out towards the estuary
towards the bar and that nobody monitors
them anyway then you can't monitor them
but in the immediate vicinity of the
slitway an attendant there
would have his eyes open he could have
he could be equipped with a
video camera and any nonsense or any you
know
bad behavior that would be recorded then
and he and they would play for
themselves and i'm pretty sure
that if this does go back with a
recommendation that that is looked at as
counter-interest put forward
okay but he's sure sean carney will come
up with the facts and figures and if we
make a nominal charge down there
it will cover and more than the cost of
having somebody so
but it was a terrible knee-jerk reaction
to seeing how this was
thanks cher okay uh simon
you're next
thanks chap um
i i didn't like the cnr uh decision
uh nor their nor their their their very
thin and limited debate um
on this um i certainly didn't like
the idea that um
[Music]
a knee-jerk reaction of of banning
things
um i also i'm gonna just stop you
we're not debating that they have banned
jet skis but we are not debating
that particular recommendation yeah i've
got that um
i would also um comment
now uh on contributions by
um counsellor councillors inch gub
and and indeed leather i'm worried that
councillors are actually
pre-judging or pre-determining a much
wider and more modern issue that needs
to be
thoroughly and properly looked at so i
don't particularly want to be told about
wardens and huts and things at the
moment that may be an answer
but until it's been looked at
holistically in the whole round
then that you know and i don't think we
should be going for
uh oh we used to do this or we used to
do that what should we be doing now
and tomorrow in that we have a modern
use of the slip there
by modern evolving um water recreation
um craft etc and we need to adapt
for it um i would suggest that actually
torridge as the authority should
hold a proper review of how that whole
area
is managed and therefore can be best
facilitated
for the majority of users
be they business people there are 13
businesses we hear using that slip
and the multitude of different types of
water
recreational watercraft users
and i think this ought to be have a
fresh look in the round
um because you know and coming into that
comes the whole issue of proper
regulation
um much of what we do there at the
moment is
by voluntary code um if we have a nasty
down there
and somebody is god forbid if somebody's
killed or seriously injured
i would have thought that actually we'll
be in the dock pretty quick
for mucking about with voluntary codes
if we are the authority
there seems to be an absence of proper
regulation down there
we hear from people from users who say
it's not sure where the speed limit
starts where it stops etc etc to me
it sounds like actually we've we've
bumbled on with a with a
a nice local uh local arrangement for
too long
well modern use of these sort of areas
now
requires proper clear regulation
where it's absolutely um clear
what is and what is not allowed and how
you do it etc and only when you do that
can it then be enforced i think that's
um one other speaker
mentioned earlier trying to enforce a
ban on any one thing or another
um as well as denying an element of the
community
their right to to conduct that activity
is is also very very difficult unless
you've actually got
a proper plan and regulation and
properly communicated
uh in order to do it so i would uh
my my understanding and looking at this
is that actually
the argument is has got a lot of
historical baggage
brought with it and actually we need to
look at it afresh
in the terms of the modern need modern
usage
you know if our fishing fleet hadn't
been denuded so much
and we actually had many more fishing
boats running out of there
um then they they would be causing a lot
of disturbance in the middle of the
night when the tide actually
had them in at that time so you know
careful what you wish for
um anyway my proposal uh chair would be
that
it's that there's a full review there
and we look at the whole thing where
and the environmental issues can be
brought into it as well and then there's
a proper
uh recommendation brought forward to
full council
in time uh having looked at the whole
thing in the round
and lastly i'm very minded by what the
local community say and i'm very
minded by the mayor of northern town
council who
came up and spoke uh very strongly on a
unanimous um instruction he'd received
from his council thank you
shirley you're next thanks very much
thank you um i i do want to say that um
i totally respect and i'm grateful for
the responses that we've had by a lot of
people
um in a lot of information has been sent
around and the majority of it has been
very sensible
and um helpful difficult because there's
often different opinions
but also some you know genuine solutions
offered as well which
which you know has been um interesting
um i i feel the slick way is for
launching things
but it has its limitations and the whole
area has its limitations the car park
has its limitations
uh we can't control absolutely on the
water but we can control the car park
so that's one thing that could come into
an overall review
um i i am concerned about the safety
issue i mean when i called it in i did i
did mention that i was against a barrier
but i was still minded to take note of
the fact that this could be a safety
issue and therefore we have to look it
very sensibly
and very carefully and i have um
i'm not local to ecuador but i have
spoken to as many people as possible and
i do
i i'm just relaying what i found and i
believe
there is quite a strong local opinion in
appledore
um several residents
aren't very fond of the jet skis in
terms of they find them
noisy etc however um
i don't want to just focus on that
um i think there's a lot of things as
counselor newton says that come into
all this uh and i do i agree with him
that i do think the whole thing needs
looking at
um so uh because i would like the safety
properly looked at and researched so
we're not making any sort of knee-jerk
reaction that focuses on one particular
group
i think there's been things raised
particularly by the
jet ski um users about possibly using
licensing
so that might be a better way to go so
at this point
uh um rather than just specifically say
um the um about having um
recommending that it goes back to cnr to
just look at
uh some look at it again but with a
particular focus on the ward and i do
agree
with councillor newton that although it
would be a lot of work i think the time
has come that we need a
a full review of the whole area and the
issues that it involves so that we
can honestly make the right decisions um
based on all the information that comes
in
thank you thanks thanks sherry steve
it's your turn mike um let's let's stacy
speak first i suspect that she's gonna
say what i was gonna refer to in terms
of the way the discussions going
okay stacy yeah thank you um just to
clarify um
this came from a notice of motion that
was submitted
on the 10th of august to full council
and as every member knows and just to
explain to members of the public
and councillors are entitled to submit
whatever notice of motion
um that they feel they want to now this
particular notice of motion
it is within the report but i'm just
going to read it out again just for
clarity
so it says with the ever increasing use
of the slip way
and river by various crafts i am
becoming
greatly concerned over safety and noise
pollution
i propose from next easter that because
we appear not
to be able to police the river that we
ban the launching of jet skis in
apple door thus reducing the volume of
high-speed
craft close to apple key and minimizing
the likelihood of accident injury
occurring
however there would still be a facility
for jet skis to launch at bank and
biddeford
keeping the density at high water speed
out now that
that notice of motion was agreed by full
council to go
to cnr and that was the issue that cnr
were debating and that issue only and i
think the difficulty that i i can hear
from today's discussion are we really
really
detracted far away from that actual
notice of motion
it was whether we want whether members
wanted to support
um the notice of motion or not and and
clearly at cnr
it did get that support now all the
other debates
are not what was originally on the table
and and it's now changing quite
dramatically out to a whole review which
obviously we
we could do and if members were so
minded but that isn't what what today is
about and it isn't what this notice of
motion is about
okay thanks for thanks daisy right
can i can i jump in there please pete
can i
jump in on what stacy said yeah okay
come on
stacy what i what i've called in
is cnr's decision not
not what went to cnr but what we're
calling in
is their decision their decision makes
no reference to what the actual
notice of motion was their decision was
to
put bullards up and and etc so
you i think you're actually um
off not focusing on the right bit the
the
what we're discussing today and the
calling
is actually cnr's decision notice
it's not we're not calling in the notice
of motion that went to cnr
and these have actually turned into two
different things
do you want to answer that stacy i do
and and
the the the notice of motion went to cnr
and that that was what cnr based their
decision on they're directly relevant
because councillor ford's notice of
motion was to ban jet skis launching
from apple door
and cnr decided that that apple door
slipway would be closed to jet ski so
it is directly relevant and my concern
is
that was all that was up for discussion
at cnr was councillor ford's notice of
motion and that's what officers put
forward
was simply council affords notice of
motion
because it it isn't for officers to kind
of make a determination as as to how
members may or or may not go we simply
put that forward
with no supporting facts now cnr had
decided that they wanted to support
councillor ford's note of promotion
which is why the suggestion of bollards
uh was put on the slipway and that is
the decision that you're calling in
so councillor ford's notice of motion
cnr's decision
based on councillor ford's notification
and that is what's been called in
so basically what would what we're
discussing
is whether there should be bollards
there
or not yeah
well chair if if ons don't agree with
the decision made from cnr
you can refer it back to cnr with with
your recommendations
but those are the facts between us so
it's come from the notice of motion
submitted by councillor ford in august
last year
cnr wanted to you know i think at that
stage recognized that there was
potential difficulty
and want to support that note of motion
and and to be fair it's only laterally
that we've had all the representations
and i'm i'm not commenting on the
representations at all
but those representations weren't
weren't there at the stage it was
presented to
full council first of all and then cnr
and i think that's the difficulty
okay thank you right okay
um some some have disappeared now
counselor pennington then come on
yeah just to say going back to stacy's
discussion
um and thank you for your advice stacy
thank you chair for let me speak again
um could cnr have made a recommendation
that they looked at the wider issue in
the conclusion they came
about the bollard so you this is
specifically about the bonds i accept
that
but i think cnr was failing and and and
not well what is the wider implications
here and could they have not made a
recommendation in response to the
the uh motion of coaster ford uh
stacy just for guidance on that please
hey
there so this emotion was originally
presented to full council
and that full and full council agreed
with that notice of motion now
if the emotion to be amended it would
have to have had council of ford's
agreement at that stage
but that that was the notice that was
approved by full council to go forward
to cnr for discussion so the time for
amending
the notice would have been that full
council on the 10th of august
with council ford's um approval because
otherwise
as members will probably understand if
you put forward a notice of motion and
it was amended
laterally then you may not be very happy
about that
okay but that begs the next question
then stacy does any of our call-ins and
there's five of us that made call-ins do
they stand
or does this meeting no this agenda item
no fail because none of our
call-ins appears are uh
viable um
should you want me to come back yeah
yeah please stacy so
yeah it is viable um council pension
because you you called in
see a nice decision made on the 1st of
february
thank you thank you stacey okay
um okay we i'll i will take roselock now
she's been waiting
such a long time and then it's you dude
yeah i'd just like to say i was on cnr
when you took
this decision in fact i proposed the
recommendation
i would just like to add that motion
went through 7-2
and we just made the decision on the
information that we had in front of us
it's only since
that all this additional um information
representations have come forward so i
i still say that um community resources
made the decision on the information
that they had in front of them
yeah thanks rose jude thanks
i'm just a little bit confused so are
you actually saying
that the jet skis have actually been
we've decided that they're going to be
banned
so we can't do anything about that
the calling is not about the banning of
the jet skis
that th they they took cnr took this in
two parts
and this is the part the second part of
it um
about the bollards going on to a
top of the slipway yeah
and and that is the only thing that we
can discuss we can't discuss
you know whether they've made the right
decision to ban jet skis
or not at this moment and the jet skis
are banned
at this stage i would like to publicly
apologize to the public that have come
in here and
said their piece i'm so sorry thank you
that's not that's that's not as we were
led to believe coming to this meeting as
committee members and if that's the case
then i will raise a notice of motion
to to revisit that whole that whole
decision because um
um i i i think we've we've let people
dance on this if this is the case i'm
not happy okay i think there's a couple
of things we
mean we need to make clear sorry to to
interject but
there's a couple of points i think we
need to make clear so the decision
hasn't been implemented because it's
been called in
so jet skis years or nobody is currently
banned from using
the slipway neither are there any
bollards in place
because uh this this committee has
called that decision in for
for consideration so cnr's decision
um about bollards was to facilitate
the banning of jet skis uh obviously at
that point
um the imposition of bollards um
didn't necessarily consider the wider
impacts on other residents and users
which have obviously
become apparent uh since that
decision notice and that decision was
published so that's the bit
this committee is called considering
whether the imposition
of bollards to facilitate the banning of
jet skis is the right thing to do or not
so basically see what you're telling us
is that uh because they took they voted
on this in two parts
uh both of them both parts come into
play
there isn't there isn't two parts
there's there's one there's
there's one this the notice emotion
was in respect of banning jet skis
because
of the considered increase in health and
safety issues
and in order to mitigate or eliminate
that health and safety issue um
cnr decided uh that the best way of
doing so
was to put bollards it on the slipway
to stop jet skiers launching
but obviously by virtue of doing that
it's
imposed something on the wider community
and wider
users which may as
it seems may not have been considered or
understood
at that point that the report was
presented and considered
obviously the report was based on the
notice of motion
which was simply about jet skiers it
wasn't about looking at other users
and other impacts so the notes of motion
and the report
was principally and solely about banning
jet skis maybe we should
we should send it back to cnr and
stating that they
that it needs to be looked into a little
bit more in thora
thoroughly then then what what it was in
the first place
because obviously there is a lot of
a lot of unrest about this situation
um anyway i've got some answer i've got
um
chris leather's been waiting too long
don't be too long chris you're
you're going well thanks chair thanks
for letting me speak again
it's just that the the actual resolution
that was called in said that the
closure outdoor slipway for jet skis
with suitable bowlers being positioned
to enable continued access for swimmers
and canoeists and the decision for bank
end
to be left to the harbour board be
agreed that's what they voted
on so it's a wider issue than just
putting bola it actually spoke about
banning jet skis
and bank end and nobody's mentioned
anything really about bank ending
biddeford
which is in which is actually in the
harbour in benefit and you couldn't use
jet skis in the harbour
i believe that's a harbor masters
problem well it's ours
the harbour massacre is employed by
torrey controls the orbit though i mean
it is a wide-ranging issue
i know that the committee the overview
and scrutiny committee have got to
decide on the actual thing that was
voted on but the discussion
should be wide-ranging overview and
scrutiny
that's what overview and scrutiny is
supposed to do and then when you address
the actual
call-in matter which i just read out
that's it but i mean it is a wide issue
i think we i think we are dealing with
it in a wide issue to be honest
counselor
right tony inch
sorry chair because i went offline for a
bit when when stacy was making a
statement about
uh that so does that mean that my
um proposal is is uh is wrong and
and i can't put that proposal through um
because uh as i say i i
my internet went down just as stacy was
making a statement
um is that is that the case mr chairman
stacy do you want to answer that
but that recommendation um can go to
um cnr um since ons can make that
recommendation to cnr but i think
councillor
sorry my um internet went down a little
bit as you were doing your proposal but
i think i've got it
um but i i was just clarifying um
because there was a lot of talk about um
information provided and just clarifying
what the original notice of motion was
and that that was what was presented to
cnr and that's what cnr made their
decision on
the notification that was presented and
and in large
um councillor ford had proposed that um
the the
slipway was closed for jet ski users
only
and that's how c r came to that that
decision um so i was just
providing that clarification now it's
over to wear an estimate whatever
recommendation
they would like to cnr i've seen i don't
have to
um agree with that um they can they can
do it if
they would say wish and if not if
there's any dispute between cnns then it
will ultimately go back to full council
okay well mr cheering i just come back
then on that and just sort of
you went funny sorry
i am a bit funny um mr can you hear me
now okay
yeah just just to say that just to start
off my recommendation
before that first sentence to say that
ons
recommends that no borrowers are placed
on the slipway and then go on to say
that cnr
considers restated the warden and
and then the rest of it as i've as i
said earlier on
if if the seconder is okay with that
i'll i'll second that chair yeah okay
just just keep that recommendation ready
if you're gonna
if you're gonna put it on uh peter ames
oh thank you chair um yeah just to start
point out that i abstained at northern
town council because i felt i might have
pre-judged
esu coming to this committee um
yeah i just wanted to clarify so we can
go to cnr
and say um ask them to so reconsider the
bollards but we can't ask
them to change the decision to ban jet
skis is that right
no i don't think that's quite right
stacey could you just answer that
you can make any recommendations to cnr
um
that that you would like um i think so
sorry i'm probably confusing things a
little bit but i was just clarifying
that the reason why c and i had come to
the concise decision because they were
presented with that notice of motion
um and that's the only thing that they
had
um when they were presented with the
report um
and i i think latterly this is when
we've had the further
so i was just trying to balance the
fairness really that when this matter
originally came to cnr
they were presented with the notice of
motion they had no other supporting
information
um they they made the decision based on
health and safety reasons at slipway but
today ons can make any recommendations
that they would like to
to cnr um but it it yeah it was just
clarifying what cn heart
had presented to them at the stage and
made the decision i can't
but can't see and i'll recommend to full
council that
um the the decision to ban jet skis is
overruled they can't do that can they it
has to happen be a new motion doesn't it
presented to council
um that that decision is reversed
so cnr can stand with their original
decision
or accept the recommendation of ons
um if there is a dispute so if they
if ons for example today made a
recommendation to cnr
and cnr agreed with that recommendation
then that decision would be implemented
if they didn't agree with ons
recommendation
um then it would have to go to full
council to make an ultimate decision
okay all right yeah i mean i'd like to
say
i'm a bit disturbed by this thing about
business and tourism
and modern modernizing all of the words
were used
i mean it is a big issue for
particularly for people in apple door
the
the effect of jets or some jet skis on
the estuary and on the slipway
and you know it's a balance between
encouraging business and tourism
and and these other factors
and i should remind counsellors is an
ssi as well the history
um huge impact and animals um
so yeah i mean this the tourist season
is looming
and i mean it would be good really it's
great to have a review
and everything going on and on for
months and months but it's an urgent
situation coming up in appledore in the
sl
on church fields there um with
too many people sort of mingling
together and
so there's a lot of different interests
and just huge pressure on on that
site really so i mean if there if we
could get a warden in
just know immediately to sort of
try and supervise the situation as a
start that would be great
thank you simon you're next or steve did
you want to come in first
um james it's only kind of in response
to councillor haines
uh what kind of james was uh just uh
discussing
so you know it seems that
um the the opinion and consensus
is that the decision has had
consequences
to the wider community and wider
residents
and so it appears though the feeling
might be that is
it's reconsidered by community resources
because there are wider implications
to the decision than have been
considered obviously
state and that's what stacy's mentioned
at the start where we heading into
is trying to find solutions at this
stage
but really all you're considering is
that the cnr decision in your view
if that's the view you formulate at the
end of the day
discussion debate is that um needs to be
reconsidered because they're much wider
implications
by the imposition of ballards
i agree with that steve rather than
trying to come up with a solution saying
it would be best
to consider doing this then you start to
be really specific
about um the recommendation rather than
leaving it
the same article so what you just the
way you've just put it is that
it would give cnr a much better scope
to look at thinking which would be
better than trying to
for us to start saying they need to look
at this
thing in particular or that uh with
with too much this says it all really to
be quite honest
that's right if it's very specific and
so you know i don't agree with that
then we kind of end up with things going
on and on if
it's left i guess to you as a committee
if you reach that resolution that you
don't
agree with the recommendation because of
the wider implications
and you need that reconsidered then it
gives a bit more
scope uh for reconsideration doesn't it
yeah yeah too right i agree with that
simon
yeah sorry my f final piece on this one
um
just coming back to to to the number the
the discussion that
stacy was having there i mean the the
report we
have um from head of communities in
place the purpose of the report
quote is to scrutinize decision of
community and resources committee
that and then as written on the screen
and that um
is the closure of the slipway to jet
skis
and the use of suitable bollards and so
it's not just bollards it's actually the
closure of the
it's a prevention of the use of of the
the slipway by jet skis
bollards is purely a means to an end um
i uh would fully support uh the wise
words of steve there that um
um we we go back and and
and say that you know the
there are many more factors that need to
be brought into the decision-making
process
uh here and that we recommend
that um the the whole use
of whole use and regulation or control
of the
slip way um by members of the public
and business um be uh be looked at again
um and this is just purely you know
flagged up an issue
um i would agree that we shouldn't be
going back with anything specific it's
not our job and
nor are we in a position to make
specific recommendations um uh
here but as my view my mind is that
there's clearly a need
for a a wider wider review
and um that yes the tourist season is
amongst us but that that's not
it would just be another knee-jerk
temporary short stop
uh reaction if we somebody tried to make
a decision now
um so i'd say i would stick with my view
that um uh in the light of what has
come out since the cnr decision
that there's many other factors to be
considered and we recommend that cnr
actually um
[Applause]
have a wider implication they we
recommend
that cnr uh go back to full council with
a recommendation
of a full of of a proper review on this
no but but we yeah i don't i don't
really think we need to
mention full council well no but that
would happen automatically because
so the recommendation would be because
uh we that we don't agree with
with their decision yeah and that um
we recommend a wider um
the wider implications are
are discussed yeah
the the the take account of the needs
of the community business
recreation etc and the environment
it's got to be informed by a proper
report from officers about all the
implications the costs and alternatives
you can't just talk about it enough
without information what would happen
peter this is what
the officer would have to do i mean
there's a lot of work in it but it's
clearly an
important issue that that and it needs
proper
updated um plan and regulation to
support that plan
so basically then what we can say then
is this is what we're going to recommend
to
uh back to see you know that way we
don't agree with their
their decision but we have to say that
we don't agree
steve did you say something
no all right i thought you you wanted to
say something
so joe we don't have to say we don't
agree we could say we are concerned
well okay we say we're concerned it
might be easier to vote for it for me
anyway
i i i i personally would say i don't
agree but um
so would i to be honest because we don't
agree with that's why we're sending it
back to
cnn because we don't agree being
concerned about it doesn't actually
really say anything um anything for us
not from england anyway
to say that we don't agree
that would be in my proposal chat um if
you want me to make a proposal
do you want to propose that yeah i would
propose that on with the
wording that we don't agree yeah and and
i i will second your proposal
that we come on what what is the
recommendation then
i think that's why i was just gonna ask
we need we need a clear statement where
the recommendation is
please if it comes to a newton could
uh put that okay to the members of the
committee
give me talk about yourself a minute i
mean just writing down something
i think we've talked amongst yourself
enough okay
i've got councillor hodgson with a hand
up as well all right sorry
sorry um where are you then
all right
come on a quick a quickie claire come on
like very quickly um i think we need to
be looking at the
entire apple door waterfront because
there are other
means of accessing the river and we
don't
want to not consider though if we're
reviewing
the uh waterfront usage at appledore
because we could be making just a
decision on appledore slipway
and not actually looking at the other
points of
access when we're making our
considerations
some of these have been mentioned
already this morning please so i mean
the recommendation that we're going to
put forward this should include this
sort of stuff anyway
well as long as it's clear that it does
and it's not specific to applejack's
flipway that's all i wanted to
ask thank you okay
simon are you ready no um sorry
come here
[Music]
okay is this war and peace
surely well it's just on what council
hudson just said
i'm that confuses me more because i
thought that we
we've got to look at the actual um
resolution was that the closure of
apple's slip way for jet ski so
we're supposed to be that's what it says
we're supposed to be focusing on an
apple door slip way
not the whole of water access in ecuador
right we can work that in we can work it
in we can work it in
yes but we're not supposed to i thought
do whatever we want shelly come on you
know
come on come on simon get a grip yeah
chair
um steve dengue when we go to the
forward plan
we do have the estuary strategy down to
look at
perhaps that might be an area where we
should pick up on some of the wider
implications as well
okay we can do that yeah thanks steve
i was going to say something along the
lines that
um are you writing your memoirs or
something
no no shut up given um
given further information that is
available
we do not agree the decision by cnr
get all this down sandra
yeah thank you chair to bang jet skis
however we recommend a full review
is undertaken
of the use
of the apple door slipway
okay and surrounding
um and
or and neighboring access points
something like that
um covering um
in involving all all
the wider implications we need to you
need to get something in there
but wider implications there's a wider
implication so yeah i mean
you know with with we're talking about a
holistic review that will
will cover
[Music]
requirements of business recreation
the local community parking
the environment um all of those
different factors now you know that is
covered if you say wider implications
yes i think so so we don't need to be
too specific
no we don't need to be specific because
what happens if we do
specific the officers will look at those
specific things yeah yeah right
where is same wider implication they'll
look at
everything that you know so not one
petite thing in particular what we don't
want to do is for it
for them to look at one thing or two
things then take it back to cnr
and then it all gets cocked up again
yeah quote
well i'm sorry i'm going to butt in here
but what we mustn't forget
is the safety issue it all came about in
the first place because of concerns
about
safety i'm into it though shirley sure
all that will come into it surely okay
bound to be part of it surely
okay so we've got the recommendation
yeah i think stacy would like to come in
i'll say so can you give us a
recommendation come on
yeah i'm looking through um how we deal
with stuff within our constitution and
trying to
to work out how to enable this for for
members and i
with the recommend i understand and i've
listened to it to what members are
saying you know and
it's very sensible but i i'm just trying
to deal with the kind of current issue
that we've got
now cnr had made this decision based on
that i hate to labor the point but based
on the the notice of motion
yeah so that they can you can only
really make a decision
based on that note of motion so if it
goes back to cnr
now they it's going to be very difficult
for them to affirm this decision or not
a firm's decision because what members
effectively want is
is a review so my suggestion would be
today if members aren't in agreement
with
closing the slip way then you make that
recommendation to
cnr and cnr decide or not decide whether
to follow record
follow ernest's recommendation
and if they can't decide then that that
bit will go to full council but if
members want a full review
then that goes separately elsewhere
because it is it's bigger than the
actual issue
bigger than the notice of motion and
it's going to be a massive piece of work
now if if c and r agree with ons
recommendation
not to have the bollards and that's it
that will be done the next time it goes
to cnr
if not we've still got kind of the issue
outstanding for quite some time
does that does that kind of make sense
because the only
thing that we can do today is refer it
all back to cnr
saying you don't agree but i think if
you want a wider review then we can do
that but i think it would be
separate to the actual decision that you
called in
if if we if we start if we take out
mention in review and just recommend
that c and r look at the wider
implications
of of of having bollards
there because we don't agree
that we that we should that we should be
putting bollards
on the slipway but they need to look at
the wider implications
if the if if that happened
chet i think that's gonna because when
cnn made the decision they didn't have
the wider implications in front of them
so i i think if if ons are
reminded to disagree with cnr's decision
then
then
you say we recommend the bullard's
armpit in place
then that goes to cnr and cnr decide
whether to stand by their original
decision to put bollards or
confirm ons recommendation now if they
confirm o else's recommendation
not to install bullard's then that
decision will be implemented there and
then and that that's that part done now
if members want a wider review
you can have that but i think it's
probably sensible to have it done
separately and then a full report
could come forward to all councillors of
all the issues
because there's massive issues including
that and i'm just thinking i mean it
won't be my report thank goodness i
think it'll be our head of communities
in place but
it's probably going to take some time to
get that report in front of members in
the meantime
you're going to have this outstanding so
that that
it's not for me to to make um just you
know to
say what you should put forward but that
would be the cleanest way of dealing
with this today
and then this one would fall away and
you can have a further review later on
okay i would can i amend my
my proposal yeah okay
i would i would i would amend my
proposal
in fact stacy by by putting the wider
implications
or using the wider implications as the
reason
why we are um not agreeing
so in fact one it triggers the other
without putting it at the end
and i would say due to the wider
implications
um ons do not agree
the decision by cnr so
we've actually put the wider input
but we do not agree the decision by
cnr to exclude
or close the apple door slipway for jet
skis
with bollards now we've mentioned wider
implications
but we've actually used it as part of
our justification for saying
why we don't agree but that hopefully
will trigger cnr to think more widely
yeah
i agree with that that's what we'll put
forward to
say just a second if i if i may
and councillor leather's just put up a
very salient point
on the the chat um because you're
talking about the
bollards what you haven't considered is
the
ban of jet skis so are you saying that
you don't agree with the bollards as a
mechanism
or are you saying you don't want the jet
skis
steve if if the bollards don't go up
there they can't stop the jets keys
can they please
sorry that's that's correct chair
we're saying is because we're looking
basically
at uh at the bollards
that is that is basically that is the
part two bit
of uh of what they they had in the first
is what comes to ons
yeah but the bonus are the bollers are
there position there to facilitate
the banning of jet skis yeah well this
is true
they can't ban the jet skis that's right
i would be more specific in my proposal
then and actually include the banning of
say that do not agree the banning of jet
skis
and the closure of apple door slipway if
we can say that but
um i
[Music]
thought we'd just got a nice
recommendation now it's all changed
yeah sean would like to come in i
believe right sean
your next chair just a really quick
point i think steve raised the main
point was it was it's about the
principle of the ban
that that needs to be addressed here
yeah you could you could
put up a sign that says no jet skis
and effectively say that you're banning
jet ski uses but how in practical terms
how are we actually going to stop
anybody doing that people just roll up
down there
they'll launch we won't have anybody
looking at it there are other ways of
doing
it they're just not affordable they're
not practical they're not reasonable
um we could look into those so so i
think at the moment it seems to me that
the debate has been going around and ran
around
and you don't agree that you are in a
place this council is in a place to
decide whether a ban is a good idea
or whether or whether putting bollards
there is a good way of introducing a ban
so you you're sort of you're questioning
the whole decision
of cnr which of course you're entitled
to do so
but sean i think it was tristan good
he's does he run this club this jet ski
club
and and they were offering to put um
signs up and everything weren't they
they they were asking to do that
to try to stop the the stupidity of some
of the jet skiers
so that's right chair but that wouldn't
be introducing a ban you see that would
be finding a way of permitting jet ski
launching
and that isn't what the notice of motion
was about exactly
yeah so so you're basically saying here
in a nutshell
you don't agree with either part of
cnr's decision
you don't want to you don't think you're
ready to introduce a ban
and you don't think the bollard's the
right way to do it if you did introduce
a ban correct
so yeah yeah yeah
that's right that's right
but we're not going to debate this for
much longer because
blimey okay okay
because the decision has been called in
and i'm sure
uh the next cnn is the 22nd march we're
nothing to come up there
so the next cnn is on the 26th of april
um so jet skis can't be banned so the
final decision is made is that correct
that's right you've got it so this could
go on
for months really okay
at the moment there's a cnr uh community
resources committee meeting next week
so there is a line on the agenda to
consider
in the event that a recommendation comes
forward from
scrutiny you know if cnr agree with your
recommendation then it can be
um implemented it's only where this
stacy mentioned earlier disagreement
between the both committees
that then it will be go on further so it
depends what your recommendation is
and whether cnr um agree with that
recommendation
um as to whether it's resolved um
next week or there needs to go further
right okay
can i try another um can i try another
wording then please aren't you
come on then you're on it right okay due
to the wider implications
ons do not agree the decision of cnr
to ban the use of jet skis
or the closure of appledore slipway
with the use of bollards full stop
i'm happy with that have you got a is
there a seconder
yeah me joe
yeah right okay joe right so we've got a
proposal and a second
coastal peninsula i've just let
councillor pennington speak and you're
the last one phillip okay
yeah just to say um going back to the
situation of tony
uh inch country intercontinental gov
proposed a second have they
draw on their original proposal um and
that that should um be questioned
because that should be taken precedent
as the first
proposal have they withdrawn that
proposal
tony would you like to withdraw
well in the circumstances i think yeah i
think i was saying that much simpler
than
cancer newton but still um and i said it
about uh half an hour ago but
there you go that's debating that's
committee for using them so i will
withdraw it yes
okay are you happy with that jude yeah
thank you very much happy birthday so
we're going with
councilman newton's recommendation uh
he's proposing it and joe manley
is second in it yes so
yeah jack don't you seek a point of
clarity on catching newtons
yeah you could you could he could he can
really talk to you
yeah no he mentioned use of jet skis
does it mean launching of jet skis
because i think we've got no way of
regulating people using
jet skis on the suv it's the launching
objectives on the split base
our management issue yeah change the way
to launching
simon yeah nice
okay uh
sandra thank you chair sorry
let's go to the vote sandra okay thank
you sorry can we just check
councillor manny's happy with the change
oh yeah yeah oh sorry sorry yes joke
you happy joe i'm happy i'm always happy
pete
[Music]
okay can we go to the vote sandra
thank you councillor watson oh
councillor haynes abstain
council about him four
councillor hawkins paul
councillor gab very much for
councillor langford for
councillor manley or
councillor inch for councillor newton
four mr dengate
abstain mr harper
four
so that's nine four and two abstentions
okay that so that that that goes forward
back to see you know
okay
right
does anybody want to go to the toilet
quick two minutes yeah before we start
the next one
speak up right often
yeah i'm going you got two minutes
oh
[Music]
[Music]
um
um
hmm
i'm back right everybody back
i'm back right okay yeah i don't think
councillor haynes is back here
right
okay don't need he's back
is everybody else back who's on the
committee
yes chair looks like they are yeah
i think shell is nodded off
right everybody ready
right okay right we got on to our next
item
which is
the calling player is strategy
like lack of maintenance budget
allocation
and we are we are looking at community
and resources resolved on the 1st of
february
that there be no allocation of a
maintenance budget for play areas
okay um
okay let's philip pennington you called
this
in yes chair i did call it in right
do you wish me to speak may i speak go
on you can have a couple of minutes come
on
yeah thanks you're a very um interesting
discussion on the first of february cnr
um and show the divided nature of
turrets basically because the
four people against it was a 5-4 vote
before
against um there'd be no allocation were
a bit of her town councillors
the other five um were non-bitter town
councillors and that
just really shows the divide that is
across towards here between urban and
rural
uh very simply very quickly because
you've had a long debate previously
i am concerned there is no allocated
budget we put
an external ons
we discussed on the 18th of november a
very extended discussion went forward
um the report that was there a lot of
pages
which included a report from tivoli on
the state of some of the park areas
and i have to say victoria park was in a
very very bad state
um it was described as poor the only one
that was described as core actually
but there was a lot of issues there and
some of the areas were hazardous
hazardous uh in that report i also noted
on report on page 24
that uh the target spent 410 000 pounds
of maintenance
in the last six years which works out
roughly about 70 grand a year
um in a wire aspect i am always
concerned about the way
towards puts capital projects forward if
you think about the cattle market
uh adhesively we got into difficulties
because we put a morris miner
in instead of a porsche i think andrew
weight once reported
um and uh having also trouble with the
borders at holdsworthy
there was some discussion ons that the
borders weren't up the standard with
again the capital cost
and i think we're in a real danger here
of being caught out by
not having allocated budget for
maintenance
i had a resident whose granddaughter had
their arm broken
in the torch play area or had a or broke
her arm in the target
area i say and i just think we make
ourselves vulnerable
because we if we are saying there's no
money allocated
to service our play areas we make
ourselves
quite vulnerable to some future um
legal action we must show that we can
maintain what we put in place
and i want to reach a challenge this
decision i think is fundamentally wrong
that there is no budget that um that is
there put aside
so we don't have to go to the discussion
about oh have we got money for this
either we have the money um i have the
play area and we have the money to
support it and i would like the uh
decision to be sent back to for
reconsideration
thank you chair all right thank you um
wish uh i want to bring sean carney in
first sean
hello chad yeah i mean we've had lots of
debates
about this as the as the strategy has
evolved i suppose the first thing
with the public listening and and for
all the benefit of the councillors
um we we have to maintain our facilities
to ensure that they are safe
we have an obligation to do so we
regularly inspect our facilities
and we must ensure they're safe we do
that
we have the budget to do that uh that's
there it's within
uh you know if if a seat breaks we have
the money
in a responsive maintenance budget
within the property team to do that
it's just not specifically ring fence
for play so i just wanted to
allay any concerns that we don't have
any money at all
to do um repairs to players because we
do
we've also got some money set aside in
the capital programme for
for play um so that will
um be used to introduce new facilities
but one of the first uh actions set out
in or that should fall out of cascade
from the play strategy
is to look at the play areas and then
start conversations with the community
about what their aspirations are for
their local play areas
and in some instances that will mean
that they are enhanced and they might
need to be enhanced by us in other in
other instances it will mean
that they're enhanced but they might be
enhanced by the community they might
have access to funding that we don't
have access to
so it's very difficult to budget uh for
a set
sum for the delivery of the strategy
because it'll be it will be delivered in
so many different ways
so i just wanted to set your mind at
rest that we're not
negligent in our looking after play
areas that's the first thing
um we wouldn't we'd certainly have the
funds to make sure things are going
safely and the first instance enough
that i've pointed this out before
if somebody goes into a play area and
we've got something that isn't working
and we haven't got a specific budget for
it because it's a big item we would
close
that facility to make sure that the
public was safe
so what you're telling me sean there is
money there
to use for play areas so we have
yeah chair we have that we have the
money to maintain
what we've got to a specific standard
now the the question is
um i think that the strategy talks about
enhancing some areas
divesting ourselves of interest in
others you know that those discussions
are yet to be had so it's difficult to
put up
a monetary sum on what it would cost to
deliver the strategy
yeah i am comfortable that we have
uh enough budget and we are responsible
enough to maintain
what we've got to a safe standard right
without having a separate maintenance
budget for player play equipment
yeah it's it that that repairs and
maintenance
is wrapped up in another property budget
right
okay that's fine fine fine for me
right okay who's up first okay chris
leather
thanks chad well it just makes no sense
at all to me and we looked very
long and hard at this players strategy
the first one we had put before us
was very weak and it went they went away
and came back with a better one but it
made no sense at all to have a play area
strategy
and not have a maintenance budget
attached to that strategy
and the one that sean's just talked
about is a maintenance budget covers
anything
that we might need maintaining that we
own but
i'd also point out that very often and
uh
we all know that equipment breaks
swing breaks it's taken down it's not
put back again so there isn't a proper
budget as such for this
and if we're having a strategy for the
players and i accept
because i think i mentioned it at the
meeting that we talked to
town and parish councils any that may
want to take over a play area
from torres that's fine that's all part
of the strategy
but we do need a dedicated budget for
repairs and maintenance
and indeed the report talks about
maintenance
in the financial implications it speaks
about
uh having finance there ready well
if it's just out of a general pot to me
that's good enough it should be
a dedicated budget for maintenance of
play areas there's so much
needs doing in players it's not all
necessary equipment some landscaping
some fencing some is and you know
we should have that in there and
when councillor pennington and phil
spoke about
the vote on this maintenance budget
element
being five four and four against them
there was one abstention
i don't accept this divide between urban
and rural i've never accepted that
at torridge um i you know in fact
i had to go back and look at it just now
because i don't even look i just look at
what the vote was
5'4 i don't accept there's a divide at
all and i get fed up of one or two rural
members
thinking there is a divide between the
towns
and the the villages and the rural areas
but let's not forget
the majority of the residents of
torridge live in the biddy for the
northern area
but you know i i'm happy to look out for
all the rural areas
as well as biddeford and northern
torrington but we definitely
should have a budget for maintenance of
our players chair thank you okay
okay phil
unmute or mute he's just spoken
just as did you know just to disagree
with chris laron last point
i am a um technically remember i don't
have an urban area
but i'm calling this in to get a
maintenance budget and we have spent 410
000 over the last six years
on the play areas there is money being
spent and it just puts storage in a bad
light
when you put the decision numbers out
there or targets but decision notice out
there
there being no allocation of a methods
budget for
play areas if you're spending the money
the money is there
it makes us look better particularly in
the light
of the injuries recorded
incidents resulting in injuries received
on this equipment
and it makes us look vulnerable when
there has been injuries received but
then we were saying we have no budget
for play
equipment and i i think this is a really
wrong decision
in the light of the money that's being
spent
well here again i mean if if if it did
if it had been put out a little bit
better and and stating that we had
monies elsewhere that covered the
the you know the looking after the play
areas then that
that would have been uh far better but
but chair this
is is reminding me of a family budget um
do i pay the electric bill or do i pay
for the food on the table
um then one loses out
and and if you have an allocated budget
you know exactly what is available
and that is really important i think to
have so a clear
stated budget there for the play areas
okay thank you peter ames yeah thank you
chad yeah i agree
totally with councillor pennington and
leather it doesn't i mean when this came
up
um the committee i was you know really
surprised at
that decision really um it makes sense
to have a budget which is informed by
proper assessment of all the
play areas that torridge is responsible
for so you get a realistic figure
um i'd just like to ask is there an
annual inspection
of um play areas please can sean tell us
that
you should be honest yes absolutely yeah
as part of the graduate maintenance
contract
is more than annual it's weekly in fact
most of it so yeah
and so there's a report reports are done
and they're acted upon then are they
if for safety yes absolutely when it
comes to enhancement and things like
that certainly not
that's another that's another ball game
entirely thank you
simon
uh thanks chair um quick one for
councillor leather um
the the last 2011 census
the population of biddeford and northern
towns
complete towns including appledore and
westwood ho
was 28 and a half thousand people
whereas the population of torrid rural
was 35 000 people now moving on
um the um
until the strategy is is decided
it's very difficult anyway to pin a
figure
on what the amount of maintenance is
required
i'm an ons external member
i do have though quite a lot of sympathy
for the view that you can ring fence
too many things in the budgetary world
and every time you ring fence something
you actually reduce your flexibility
even more
and and i'm i'm cautious on this one
and i'm not as strong as some other
councillors
um in saying that there should be a
dedicated budget there
that there's no lack of will but
i think the council do need we do need
to maintain
the flexibility within our budgetary
system and
sometimes you know we don't know where
the other priorities are going to come
up
at the moment because the strategy
hasn't
completed its course through and then
decisions have been taken at the end of
it we actually don't know
how big the the the play portfolio will
be anyway
because there's all sorts of decisions
yet to be taken down track that haven't
been taken
so trying to pin a maintenance budget to
it
um would be is is a bit like a needle in
a haystack anyhow
um but i'm i'm i'm cautious i
i'm i'm um i hear entirely um councillor
pennington and and the others but
i am cautious because i have a mind on
other aspects of the financial piece
within the council and the need to
maintain flexibility
and one of the ways we do that is not
actually
tie down everything too much within uh
very tight uh parameters um so
that's that's my piece can i
after that can i just bring david asim
first sean
and shirley david oh okay thank you chet
just thought i'd um give some insight to
what we actually do financially with
regard
we had to have a repairs budget
dedicated
for the park so that's reactive repairs
as sean reports
we have in playground inspections and
they go out and if they find anything
dangerous
or we'll do the repairs reactive okay
and
in 2000 i mean we have about just over
27 000 pounds that particular budget
and also we have a more general backlog
maintenance reserve where we put money
into our backlog maintenance reserves
and adrian redwood in his capacity as a
property manager can use
that money for however he sees fit if
you also remember when we set the
budgets for
um going forward we assigned extra money
to our capital program for the rolling
investment just renewing our capital
portfolio and that could incorporate
some parts related equipment and we've
got the best part 250 thousand pounds
quarter of a million set aside for um
parts related capital works
okay i think the point we're missing a
little bit perhaps is that we've got a
strategy which has given us an
aspiration
and it gives us priorities and tells us
which are our parks that need the most
work first
but until we've actually um proceeded
through that strategy we don't know what
our ongoing as a councilor newton said
our ongoing capital commit
our maintenance commitments will be
because we don't know the extent of our
portfolio of parks and playground
equipment
if it's like sean alluded to some parks
transfer
to um another voluntary sector then that
responsibility transfers from the
council
so it's very difficult for us to set a
budget at the moment what i think i'm
probably trying to say is in the
roundabout way is that
we have money set aside earmarking them
and saying they're only for capital for
um only for maintenance for parts it's
probably a little bit too restrictive
for the council and in some ways it's
what do we actually deliver do we keep
the parks
maintained or do we not that's from the
question and
have we if we'd used it from a general
backlog maintenance reserve does it
really matter
i suppose that's where i'm coming from
yeah and if we just
keep earmarking pots and pots and pots
all over the place we lose a degree of
flexibility
yeah i've probably spoken too much thank
you i have to agree with that
um
so sorry david can i just come back so
the first pot of money you talked about
that you said would be useful
could be used for parks maintenance what
plot of money is that is that
it's not just for parks maintenance is
it i'm sorry i'll just explain we do
actually have
within our parks area our open spaces
area a reactive maintenance budget and i
think it's just over 27 000 pounds okay
but because it's reactive and we're
reacting to repairs that happen i've
just had a quick look well have been on
the um
meeting and in 2018-19 we actually spent
65 000 pounds on reactive
repairs in our park so we didn't stick
to the budget we look at the budgets in
the overall
separately from that adrian redwood has
access to something called a backlog
maintenance reserve
so we've we've put some money into that
every year on a recurrent basis but
also when we maybe have a surplus at the
end of the year we top that pot up
so we can use those money that money is
as well for anything he feels is
appropriate
which could include parks separate from
that we've got 250 000 pounds in our
capital program
which has a parks tag to it
um so what i'm trying to come on is that
we don't necessarily dedicated a set pot
of money for parts maintenance but
there's various
sources of finances available to the
council to actually deliver
maintenance of the past and i suppose
what i'm saying is the council probably
is best to be judged
does it maintain its parks or does it
not maintain its parks and open spaces
how we've assigned pots and money is
almost really for myself for me
the accountancy team to some degree i
don't know if i've answered your
question council langford yeah it was
just that first pot of money
it it the way you said it it almost
sounded like a maintenance budget
um apart from maintenance budget and
that that's right
yes the the only caveat i'd say is it
that's reactive repairs
so really what it is is something goes
wrong and we repair it it's not a
replacement budget
it's not a refreshment of equipment but
i think
i think that'd be an important
differential to make and maybe that's
what maybe council pennington maybe is
referring to as a
more of a replacement of equipment
budget okay so just
because sorry if i can okay chair if i
can just
say then
my gut feeling is that i i want a budget
there but i do take david's point that
there obviously just
seemed to be money there um it seems
it it feels it feels harsh if everything
has to be raised from scratch if you
know what i mean
if you did want to replace something if
uh if there's no budget then you feel as
if
um it would just you know the money
would have to be raised from some other
way i mean we talk about going out to
community or whatever which
could be ever so laborious on the other
hand i don't want there to be a budget
and therefore be limited with no
flexibility so if you did desperately
need something to replace something or
to repair something that you were then
told no the money's gone you can't
so it's a bit of a a tricky one juggling
act
i think thank you sean
thank you chad so so listening to
councillor pennington's
um concerns there were two main points
that i think
probably we can address hopefully we've
picked up the safety aspects
and and i you know you you're assured as
a committee
that however we account for things we've
got the safety of our play areas
budgeted for
okay so that that should be the first
thing there
the other the rest of it it it seems
like
a you're seeking or cancer pennington
seeking a public statement that we have
an aspiration in play and a commitment
to finance it
and that might be around we might be
able to address that in the pr
around the launch of the strategy when
we actually
go out and tell people that this is what
we intend to do
um you know we might need to set aside
specific sums of money to
convince the public that we are
committed to keeping play
um safe to developing play
and improving play for the benefit of
our residents so i i just wonder whether
it's a pr message around the launching
strategy that might help yeah okay
right phil bennington
yeah just uh thank you sean i agree with
your second point there absolutely is a
bit of a presentation of the wording
of the news that went out because i i
feel it puts storage
in in a bad light so i agree with your
second comment there sean and
david hayes thank you for your comment
about um um all the
the pots of money and all the rest of it
the one key word i think david you said
was
we are reacting to when issues arise
and i think there's a tradition in
torrance we react when the dirty water
system goes wrong
pose with it or the borders don't work
out hopefully or react when a child
breaks his arm at
the victoria park play area
we have to be seen to be proactive and i
that's all i want to make sure that we
are seeing
in the light that we are leading the way
and not responding
after something happens and i think it's
about the pr
side that is really strong and i think
the notice
gave us a bad light at torridge thank
you chair
okay david hey do you want to come on
back down there first
yeah just very quickly to council
pendleton's point about being reactive
you we have a reactive maintenance
budget
and exactly as you described it but when
we set the uh
capital budget as part of the median
term financial strategy
we set aside over the next five years
nine hundred thousand pounds into a
rolling capital programme
ad we'd into that pot that juncture say
exit out to that
is for our park some play equipment but
that's what it said very general that's
that's exactly what you're alluding to
we set aside money
knowing that at some point in time works
will be required
the only thing we did we did it as a
very general description we you know
partly car parts and the rest just been
for our general
portfolio over properties now in the
fullness of time we'll uncover whether
that's enough money that we're setting
aside but that's what we've
we did when we set the budget over the
media term financial strategy
at full council on the 22nd of february
thank you chair thank you david thank
you sean
steve um
thanks thank you david really covered
what i was just going to say
um i guess i guess the key bits on from
that
is linking that um
[Music]
programmed replacement money the
maintenance budget that david said built
into the program with the strategy the
play strategy and from the play strategy
you will eventually have
a detailed plan of the play areas
that will be retained that the council
wants to retain
and replenish improve as you go forward
and then you bring the two together so
it's it's the case i guess is we just
at an early stage with the play strategy
and needs to join these two bits
together
okay thanks thief okay chris leather
thanks chad just really for a member's
attention we did have a
condition report so that surveyed in all
the play areas
only in 2019 and for councillor newton's
information
el meadow at winkley four pieces
equipment there
two of them were action for repair now
since then they may have been repaired i
don't know but when you go through this
document
you see so much in there that hasn't
been maintained
it it breaks down or wears out or
becomes
unsafe and it's taken out of play and
that's the
issue that we ought to at least be
indicating in our strategy
that a maintenance budget will be
provided i mean
i take what's being said about with a
bit of work still to do
and we're talking to parish and town
councils about the possibility of them
taking some of these
place play areas on but we should be
indicated in this strategy
that we will be having a a maintenance
budget
because maintenance is ongoing it's not
just
you know it is replacing the things when
they
when they do wear out which of course
play stuff does wear out
and it should get replaced and i know
it's it's not a statutory requirement
but we all i think all the elected
members do place a high
value on good play provision which
storage
i'm sorry to say over past years has
been very poor in providing
so you know to have a play strategy with
no
maintenance budget attached to me is
just ridiculous
and sends out the wrong signals thanks
chad but surely
once the strategy has been sorted out
then it could be looked at to have a
maintenance budget but
in my opinion at this moment in time
there is
more than enough money there to look
after our play equipment
through the various things places of
where money is stashed
that david's been saying yep but you're
missing
sorry chair with respect you're missing
the point
community and resources accepted the
play strategy they accepted
but they took out that point that we had
in there about
the need to have a maintenance budget
dedicated to the play areas
not a general pop that you you might be
lucky and dip into and get something out
because
what's happened over the past years is
it hasn't happened
rep maintenance hasn't been happening
properly
pieces of equipment to take note from
play as i've just pointed out the one at
winkler but there's plenty in there
where a lot of the equipment is not in
use because it's been taken out of play
and it doesn't get replaced some of it
might be down to
routine maintenance it's all like doing
a safety inspection that's one thing
but routine maintenance lots of the
gates don't close on some of these play
areas
routine maintenance and without a budget
to to take up these
you know routine mentors we don't get a
proper player strategy
but but the routine maintenance it i
mean
the safety that that uh i think sean
said
um if just defeated every week
then surely these are the people that
come back and tell the council well
this something's broke that's broke the
chain's not right on the gate
and then the council use that to go out
and
and organize repairing or or if it's
that bad
they remove they remove the
the you know for safety's sake really
once a year that you have to have this
inspection yeah that once a year once
you've i understand about play
play areas very much because we've got
one down here it has to be
done once a year but actually
the parish council um look at
it every week and
and take notes of what's right with it
and what's wrong with it and if it's
something's wrong with it they have
they get it done and that's how it works
and i mean and
torridge is no different encourage
people who go and do safety checks and
these people that do the safety checks
actually report them on the condition
but once a year am i right sean
so the the play areas are inspected like
i say i think it's weekly
but i might need to clarify that that
for you definitely but very regularly
as part of our grants maintenance
contract and you know we have to do that
as an obligation to do that for public
safety
yeah exactly we know what a wonderful
ground maintenance contract we got
sure we're not discussing that council
ever
that that comes later anyway
anybody else want to say anything on
this
phil pennington do you want to come back
in yeah just to say i mean can i just
suggest other
wording i just sent it back to cnr with
our other wording on it
the the the the parts were maintained
from other budgets but don't put out
boldly
as sean kearney's previously said
there'd be no allocation of a
maintenance budget because that put
storage in a bad light
just reword the situation and reword the
motion
that that came through cnr so that we're
not seen in that light in the public
view what do you see what do you suggest
that the wording should be
i suggest that we say that there is uh
there is funds for maintenance
um for our parks from the various
budgets that
affect our green and play areas
something like that
but don't say there is no allocation of
a maintenance budget because
when a grandmother has her granddaughter
with a broken arm in our play area
and they see boldly stated out before
there is no allocation of a maintenance
budget
it's a little bit wordy
i think i agree with you phil i agree
with you i would have very happy just to
change that wording
so that we cover our backs in years to
come if there should be any injury in
our play areas
john john yeah in a minute peter
sean can you come back to that
i'm trying to unmute sorry chair i don't
know why
um so so so councillor pennington is
suggesting
that we go back to cnr refer back to cnr
and say in your decision would you make
reference
to the fact that there is a maintenance
budget
uh there is money for maintenance but
wrapped up in
in other budgets is that
is that it you know but that's what
you're saying
yeah um i mean you could refer that back
to
to see an art scene back to cnl
to change the wording yeah
yeah like why not like it doesn't it
doesn't change the decision that the
strategy is
approved that's right it's just it's
just sort of caveats
the the the vector where the money is
coming
from to do the repairs etc
that we have got money not looking for a
specific
maintenance budget because we've already
got money in other places to
to look after the play equipment that's
what it is
in it where are you oh yeah i think
stacy would like to come in
stay said you could come on you coming
thank you i was just gonna say i'm not
sure if a feral back is it's necessary i
mean obviously it's a question for
members but
the cnr decision did say not to provide
a ring
fenced budget for play um area
maintenance so
um if ons are happy with that then that
decision will be implemented today
um if not it goes back to cnr but i
think you're effectively going to have
the same result
you're not seeing a pacific ring fence
one and but
that was cnr's decision otherwise it's
delaying the decision
and to get the same result but it up to
members obviously
come on what does members think about
that
can we just not say that there's
sufficient budget allocation for the
maintenance of the place strategy
that's my view sorry stephen that's my
view i mean
i'm just trying to tell you basically
what we're saying is there is money
there what we're
trying to work out is how we express it
so on the basis that
what we're saying is that there is money
allocated
overall for the support of it then
surely the money will follow the
strategy
what stacey was saying is that it you
know we could
we could incorporate that and she's
saying that um
you know we we don't have a ring fenced
maintenance budget for play areas but we
have
um we have a budget that includes
a budget for firm um for play areas
basically that's what what she's saying
intake and that's what we could say
okay steve hearst and sean kearney would
both like to come in
come on okay steve yeah
i think i think we seem to be getting a
bit
bogged down yes in the in the the
minutiae detail of
things about what's maintenance and
repairs what's actual kind of
enhancement and the continuance of
a play area i think that's that's the
problem
um so i think we've established
in order to continue
maintaining the play areas there's
budget
available i think what's what's missing
and i i wasn't at external overview and
scrutiny
when this was considered i think what
the committee
were expressing if everywhere at that
time
there's no separate budget
for the continual replacement
of obsolete equipment at play areas
rather than the fixing some nuts and
bolts on it it when a piece of equipment
becomes obsolete is simply removed
um in some circumstances and i think
that's
what was i believe that was what was
being expressed
an external scrutiny so this this
started at external scrutiny
then cnr made a recommendation about no
maintenance i think it's probably got a
little bit confused
during the the course of those couple of
meetings
so what shawn is saying and what the
strat we think the strategy is saying
is at some point in the in the coming
months
members will determine from
however many players we got so say we've
got 100 play areas
members will determine that say 50 of
those
are retained by torridge council
and from the condition survey
we will have sufficient resources
available for the continued replacement
of equipment in those 50
areas the other 50 say will either be
transferred to the community or
transferred
to parish councils or be managed in a
different way
and when that exercise is completed we
would establish
the right levels of repair maintenance
and replacement budgets for the
strategic play areas that the council
wants to retain
yeah i finally i think that's what
and i think it's a bit of confusion over
what's maintenance
on what's um the continued replacement
of obsolete equipment
right thanks steve okay peter ames
you've been waiting long enough sorry
thank you yeah it's a bit disturbed by
this sort of reactive approach really
i mean a budget should reflect
what is likely to happen really rather
than waiting for something to be broken
um so you know the other thing is um
about you talking about obsolete
equipment well in my experience like in
epidural
church fields the swing was taken away
for like a year and it wasn't obsolete
it wasn't it was just
it wasn't repaired or replaced
so i think a budget should reflect a
sort of more proactive
i think there should be an allocated
budget i don't i mean it's clear to me
what that means and it should reflect
that's all proactively even if there was
an allocated budget
it would still go through the same
procedure prior to using that budget
right it would still have to go to i
think it's adrian's team
it would have to go through the same
procedure so all what
and and the thing is there is money
there already
uh would it just have to just do we
separate that money up and say
okay we've got a fixed budget now for
the play area but we have to go through
the same procedure
adrian has to go through the same
procedure as if we've still got the
money
where where where it is now i i just
i i don't think that me personally i
don't think it's necessary at this
moment in time
to have a a
a maintenance problem everything else
has a budget so what's your objection to
that
because there's already money there to
use
in two in two places david ases just
told us that surely
there was not clearly stated every you
know councils generally have budgets
that states clearly what they're for so
everybody knows
rather than having to rely on picking
out the sort of
yeah so it kind of links to what
counselor newton
and david hayes was referring to earlier
the lower the level of detail you go
down with the the budgets
the less flexibility you have so as has
been pointed out a certain
amount has been spent on reactive
maintenance of players
over the last years and that will vary
year to year
so if if for example we said that on
average that's 20 000 pound
so if you set took out of the general
maintenance budget twenty thousand
pounds
for play areas uh what what happens then
once that twenty thousand pound
is done to members then accept that we
stop doing maintenance and we close the
play areas
because you've lost that you've then
lost that flexibility
what you'll also probably end up with is
as the money's being used
some debate and discussion about well
surely we should allocate
10 thousand to this park five thousand
to this park a thousand
here and where you'll end up with such
low level detail
is you'll have no flexibility at all um
adrian's team in managing the property
managing the assets
will have no room to maneuver or
flexibility when certain things
are done so you can't then react or
respond to
any issues that's the kind of prime
difficulty with
having budgets at such lower level
always raiding other budgets and
simon sure um i
propose that we i propose that we do not
we do not raise a comment um on
this decision and so we let the decision
pass yeah i i will second that
nobody else stands up sandra
sandra sorry chair i'm here
are you wake up girl are you i couldn't
unmute sorry
can we go to the vote yeah
certainly thank you chair councillor
watson
ah councillor haynes
again council about him
or councillor hawkins
oh against
councillor gab against
council langford against
councillor manly or
councillor wrench against
councillor newton for
mr dengate against
and mr harper four
two three four five
yes chair that motion was lost all right
stacy can you come in here give me give
me advice
another motion yeah we'll need another
recommendation
because um that that proposal was to let
the cnr decision stand effectively
yeah um that that motion has been lost
so you need a recommendation as to what
proposal
members want to make to cnr okay
ryman um i propose that
we recommend that cnr
make adequate provision within the
budget
that adequate position sorry that
adequate provision within the budget
is made to maintain and replace
equipment in agreed play areas
right okay who wants to second that
hello when you say agreed play their
play areas
you're talking about the ones torres
will retain but i mean it could take
quite a long time to to um transfer
the other player areas which they'd
still have to be maintained wouldn't
they
they're agreed at the moment now aren't
they presumably i mean
until uh or um
all right um
to maintain or replace equipment in
in
it's got to be specific to the ones that
torrid you're responsible for at any
given time isn't it
yeah and place equipment in
um play play
areas
sorry i'll stop talking
hello okay
surely yeah could we not just
could we just not ask cnr or stacy might
say it can stand anyway but
could we just not say something like um
uh
money for uh replacement of equipment is
it available in the following budgets
and then list the budgets that dave
david hayes mentioned
i would agree to that
yeah do you want to propose that shirley
i will propose that
yeah well i'll second that then
so we've got now got a second one on the
table
okay because council langford just
repeats what the
recommendation is i think i said
uh money for maintenance you might query
the word replacement money for the
maintenance and replacement of equipment
is available in the following budgets
and then list the budgets that david
mentioned
okay yeah
i think that's okay i'm sure that's okay
steve
okay that's that's not really doing
anything it's just
it doesn't say what dave just
repeating what david says at cnr saying
the money the money is just shown in
these budgets
but if well but it could just but it
could go
in the play strategy so it's written in
black and white in the play strategy
that might reassure people that the
money is
sitting there yep that yeah that's
that's okay yeah it's just it's it's
just making things clearer i guess
yeah okay i'll i'll second that man
anybody else counselor pennington well
just to say
you're driving at the issue here i mean
i was advised that this had to go back
through internal because it was
financial
but you know crystallizing the debate
it's not about financial it's about the
actual presentation of a decision
and the motion it was put through cnr to
start with
and you know i mean the kernel issue is
okay it might delay whatever you want to
do
but it is about the presentation of that
information
that torridge does have money for
maintenance
and the word the the uh decision was was
wrong there'd be no allocation ever made
in this budget for play areas
and that's the kernel of what i was
trying to drive at
and i think that is valuable so i mean i
know uh steve will say we're not
you're changing anything but it's the
changing of the
the uh environment if you like the way
the decision was made
so that we are seen to be a proactive
council
not a reactive council i underline that
to you
simon i think i'd be more concerned
in in actually what's going to happen
rather than just giving an impression to
to people
so basically we either set a budget
or we don't so we either set a budget
and a
fixed amount of money is put aside with
a label on it
for this function or we don't
and anything else is well it's back to
what cnr have already said um
personally i i i don't agree with going
as far as setting a budget
i think we start to tie people's hands
and it's been well explained earlier
um i don't think as a result that i
still don't believe
that there's a need to say anything else
short of setting a budget because
anything else is meaningless
um other other than it just been for
external signposting but you're not
really
fundamentally you're not doing anything
because you're not making any pledge or
promise
for a financial amount um the only
meaningful thing
would be to actually insist that you set
a set of money aside for it
but to do that you've got to set a
budget now personally i think that's um
not necessary but um and we can't we
can't get involved in that today
stacy
come on i i think when this was
presented to cnr
this was more about the play strategy
and adoption of the play strategy
because the budget was set by full
council um
and and i think that's probably where
we're coming from i don't think cnr were
specifically
talking about the allocation of the
budget towards pla i think they were
just
saying yes we'd like to adopt the play
strategy the budget
is set up for council and i think that's
why um the decision is but not provide a
ring fence budget because that was going
to be dealing with later on
um i understand councillors concerns
um but it isn't as as i think you know
sean's explained it isn't that we're not
setting forward and budgets or
maintenance budgets it was just
very separate and this strategy had to
come to see and now the budget was going
to be set by full council so i think
that's why the decision is as
it is if that if that helps at all
i mean me personally i don't think we
need a ring ring thanks budget we've
already got
money cat tony inch
thank you chairman yeah i mean
i'm on the opinion that we either go
with the
recommendation by cnr or we don't so
it's a it's a
black and white situation with me so i
mean if
if members are not um happy with what
cnr have said
in their report and they voted on then
we must just put it back to cnr
that we don't agree with their decision
and they work
there are to look at this decision again
i mean that's that's that's the only way
i think we can go with this
actually right i mean we we can't make
suggestions hey they go about that
all we can do is put it back to cnr to
say that we're not
uh happy with their uh decision
i'll second that he's making a proposal
and and that
if i thought yeah i'll make that
proposal in and that's and that's black
and white then we can put it back to
them
and they can have this debate that we're
having now
councillor levers made the point in the
chat about the play strategy indicating
there'd be a maintenance budget
that will be formulated i mean can we
say there will be sufficient allocation
of a maintenance budget for play areas
than there'll be a sufficient allocation
rather than no allocation can we just
not
change the word no to sufficient
we asking that question update well i'm
just asking the question generally
because i'm picking up on
councillor lovers comment in the chat
and i'm just looking at the question
and thinking of what council of
pennington has said
about perception as well so what we're
saying is
there be sufficient allocation of a
maintenance budget which we're already
being told that we have
ch chair can i come back with my
proposal but
because all i'm saying is that that
debate will be taken
at cnr when we put it back to them so
if we say that we're not uh we're not
happy with their decision
um surely the officers will take that
sure we'll take it back to cnr
and and something else will be um
will be voted on someone else will come
out of this instead of
instead of what they've said there so
i think it's up to cnr to debate it not
for us
i think that's all we've got to do is
send it back to cnr to say that we're
not
happy with their decision
right are we sending it back with
recommendation or just are we just
failing the vote and letting it go back
okay you've got council of leathers
honda you don't know
i'm looking at it steve okay
chris thanks chad yeah just a
couple of comments i made there we did
have
a in the budget community parks and open
spaces we did have a
and i put it on the thing repairs and
maintenance responsive we did have
you know forty thousand now it's down to
twenty five thousand
in nineteen twenty but when you look
through the budget book at all the
various headings they've all got
in their budgets um responsive
maintenance repairs and maintenance
responsive
in the industrial estates we have for
the cad kazdam business center
for the managed offices at halls really
even for the key building
on the key and biddeford we've got in
their budgets
plan maintenance is a budget as an item
now
if we've got a place strategy in there
we should have a maintenance budget
mentioned
and not just cast out as if well we've
got a strategy but we don't know we're
going to maintain any
of it
right anybody want to come back there
stacy or david
okay david use faith
yeah just quickly that that's really
just looking at the budgets in a
slightly narrow way um council levying
just in terms of what's in our revenue
budget book
in respect of the reactive repairs
and maintenance we obviously have a more
general pot that adrian
in the proper team has which is our
backlog property maintenance
and obviously we have monies in our
capital programme and we've agreed at
full council in february of this year
to set aside 900 000 pounds over the
next five years for
just general maintenance of our property
portfolio
so i think that's only one aspect of the
budgets we've set aside so i appreciate
what you're saying but it's just
that's just one component
[Music]
okay only on the chair we do not get the
money spent
and this play area condition survey
survey
of 2019 shows it we don't spend the
money
well we probably don't spend the money
if there's not to spend it on
but then again okay stay safe
chad i was just going to say if this is
about budgets it's it's going to be a
full
council it's going to have to have been
far back
we cannot be just sorting out budgets
there's two aspects to it so i'm seeing
our adopted
the play strategy and i i don't
think from listening to members today
they've got any issue with the play
strategy and that
um cnr's remit but the budget and which
is why i think
they haven't dealt with the budget in
their decision it's a full council
thing so that's probably why
they haven't ring fence specifically a
budget because it's not that
um committee's jurisdiction to do so
yeah okay steve
okay just coming back on what state he
said they they can't allocate a budget
yet because they haven't determined
the the next level of the play strategy
so once the the next level has been
determined around which play areas are
going to be
retained transferred etc that's the
point
at which you'll be able to determine
the level of continued financial
resource for play
and at that point a budget is expected
to be allocated
so we kind of put enough the horse
before the car before the horse
yeah we need um to get through to the
next stage
but then cnr to consider these are the
the play areas
we will continue to retain and we are
committed
to continue at this standard of
of provision and in doing so we
will have to spend x amounts of money
and we would then recommend tefl council
a a budget uh requirement
yeah and that would come through the
capital process so at the moment
as sean indicated there's 240 000
available for play in the capital budget
um that as yet hasn't been allocated to
uh particular play areas because that's
in advance
of the play strategy moving towards
being a play
strategy action plan
thanks steve phil pennington and then we
we'll have to go somewhere with this
yeah just caught a steve's cart before
the horse i mean can you give me the
background thinking on cnr
of why they then actually said there'd
be no allocation of a maintenance budget
because of his cart before the horse
that recommendation that cnr made is
irrelevant
and they shouldn't be made in the first
place what you've got down there is now
a mandate from cnr that you know
whatever you're going to do you're going
to have a new allocation of the
maintenance budget so
you're caught before the horse but
that's what you said
uh what cnrs said um they've actually
looked at it and they said there will be
no allocation
and that's what we're discussing so to
say no it's caught before the horse i
take it back to well why is cnr coming
up with that decision chair
okay can i respond like i'm not
obviously not going to speak for cnr
members of what they thought at the time
but cnr were considering the
recommendation from external overview
and scrutiny
they weren't considering something
themselves they were considering
recommendations that were coming from
the external overview and scrutiny
committee
yeah thank you simon yeah just following
up on all of that
um although i i wasn't present at the
cnr
debate on this one but
[Music]
that i'm now therefore thinking that
actually the wording
of the cnr decision is actually the
issue
in that it's not actually and i'm not
getting it whoever put the words
together
but it's not actually very cleverly
worded
because by what various people are
saying and suggesting
and steve et cetera suggesting the
intent of that
wording is it or that wording is not
probably the intent of what what was
designed
all they were they're saying that for
the time being
um that that or there will not be an
allocation of a maintenance budget
until the strategy play strategy is
concluded
um the suggestion is more that
um so i think probably actually
it's it's a unfortunate wording which
has created all of this
rather than anything else um
yes you did write this simon
okay so where do we go with it well if
we've got concerns i mean councillor
inch is recommended we go
back to we express our concern to
community and resources and
it's no doubt people on this committee
will will
will make statements to cnr about what
the concern is and
cnr can reconsider the wording if
possible or whatever
where's tony inch he's gone
tony i'm still here all right
so all i'm saying here is if we don't
agree with it
i think what we're saying is we don't
agree with the wording and that the
decision that they made
in that wording they're all we're gonna
do is is say that we don't agree with
that decision and put it back to cnr
again
and then the debate that we've had for
the last half an hour here
will go on there i reckon okay and
officers will come up with another um
[Music]
set of words or whatever and that will
be a recommendation then and
that that will clear everything up
we've already said that ninja because my
nation failed
uh and therefore it follows
automatically that we just
say to cnr that we don't agree
yeah yeah i mean you probably don't need
to do anything more because my motion
failed
which was to leave it as it was so
therefore
you're saying you don't agree with it
full stop well
who's who's proposing that then inch
i seconded it right and then half an
hour ago
we yeah well we didn't didn't i put
forward a motion
yeah you surely put forward emotion
there's three motions how many motions
have we got on the table sandra
hello sorry chair
hi the dog's bitter oh
sorry all right
um without going back through my pages
of notes
i can't give you an exact number
straight away
um we have councillor inches
and we have a proposal from councillor
langford yeah that money for the
maintenance and replacement of equipment
is available
in the following budgets and she asked
that the budgets be listed which you
seconded i i prefer that
because it just answers back to what it
is and we haven't actually then
gone against the decision of cnr
have we because the money is already
there
steve okay i think i think with that
that one you're
um seeking clarity in the play strategy
that there is money there for
maintenance
currently and that's what that would
achieve so it's not asking for any more
money
it's just providing clarity
in the play strategy that there's
already maintenance budget
available yeah
so that would its weather is because
i think we just i think the disagreement
is still around terminology
yeah and it's terminology that stemmed
from the original some of the original
documents if you're looking
if members look on page 29 of the papers
and look at the conclusions
um in the report i'll re i'll read it
out
for members of if any members of the
public listen this strategy
and subsequent action business plans
will provide torridge district council
and the communities within the torridge
area
with a clear pathway for maintaining and
developing the play areas within our
area
whilst also ensuring that finances can
be used effectively and efficiently
so that's saying to members that you've
got
a play strategy the action plans and
business plans that come from that
will help determine and commit storage
with what finances need to be
made available and that's for the for
the longer term
aspirations of having a a clear
set of play areas that
members want to retain now the
recommendations
uh below below that from external talk
about
that the maintenance budget for players
be allocated
so if you link to those two it seems be
i guess there would be a commitment to
having a maintenance budget
once those action and business plans are
developed
so i guess and i can't remember which
member around the table said
i suspect members of cnr
were minded to wait until that piece of
work has been done
before allocating a specific budget so
rather than allocating a budget at that
at the point of the meeting needing to
understand
exactly what's required because
otherwise you'll just be putting a
finger in the air
suggesting that you might have a
maintenance budget for everything
where eventually you might not have all
the play areas
so i think members of cnr were probably
thinking
but we'll do that once that position
is known so i guess today
members are concerned yes concerned that
there's no budget being allocated
but are you wishing to go back to cnr
and saying
we have concerns that no budget being
allocated
but assuming that's on the basis
that this secondary piece of work needs
to be done
first and that you will be considering
allocating a budget
once that's done so you've
you're concerned that there's nothing
there but are you
concerned that there's nothing there
because that other piece of work hasn't
been done
it depends largely on
what members of cnr were thinking
when they made that um original
recommendation i guess it would have
been
helpful if it had specifically said that
no allocation of budget is done
at this time until
the work had been done then you would
have been um explicitly
clear of of their rationale for coming
up with that if they
said we don't believe there's any need
to make any budget provision
then that's something completely
different isn't it we want clarification
chair don't we it's up to see an art say
what they meant
you know
okay okay but but you can you can
if you could possibly make your
recommendation
that you have concerns that if they were
if their recommendation is such that
there was never going to be
a maintenance budget set aside for play
then you just then you disagree with it
if
your concerns are that there's no
maintenance budget
but you accept if cnr were considering
that
that larger piece of work first with a
viewer set in a budget
at that time then that alleviates your
concerns doesn't it
yeah you may have concerns later on
when that recommendation is made that
it's not sufficient
um but that's a separate consideration
at the moment we're trying to
resolve um a call in
on something we're making some
assumptions around how that decision was
reached
yeah can i come in check i i can't raise
my hand and i've been listening to the
debate
um and you will notice that um i
actually propose the recommendation what
steve has said is correct
at the time i asked the question how big
would the maintenance
budget be and the answer was until we
finalized the play strategy there was no
way of knowing
how big the budget would be therefore to
fix a budget
that may be grossly overestimated or
totally
insufficient would not achieve anything
until the place strategy had finalized
the number of areas and what the
intention was to do and obviously
at the time we hadn't set the budget but
as david has said on several occasions
this morning
there is room within the budget to cope
with the position we're in at the moment
so um so basically you're going round
and round in circles
um and probably yes the wording could
possibly been slightly better to say at
that time we were not setting the budget
because you had not finalized the closed
strategy
um and you cannot set a budget by
putting your finger in the wind
and hoping it's going to be a sufficient
or b
we have not been clinched a load of
money in the budget
that we could use for other purposes so
that is my comment thank you
thanks ken
right tony inch where i
yeah well i mean that's what my
suggestion my proposal is trying to say
let me
take it put it back to cnr now again
and tell them we don't agree with that
statement that's all we're going to do
and and then the officers like steve
others have said
that they'll come up with that with that
different
um different word in them won't they
yeah okay they should do anyway i mean
you know if we just say that we don't
agree with that statement that there
will be no allocation of maintenance
budget for play areas
we think that's wrong which we all think
that's wrong
so then they will come back with a
a different statement hopefully
to reassure us all and
and then they will they will be able to
say what they were thinking at that time
when they
took that boom
okay because i'm not sure let's go
go to the vote
what are we going to the vote with
councillor inches proposal
right well i would i would draw i would
draw mine then
you'll just go with counsellors yeah
right is there any other notice on
no i don't think so so what we're
looking at now
is the recommendation from councillor
inch
and peter ames has seconded it yeah
sandra can i read out the pro
sorry did i interrupt someone
doesn't matter about the rest you carry
on can i
can i just get clarification on the
um recommendation um
that we do not agree
with the statement of cnr
that there there will be no allocation
of maintenance budgets from play areas
right and that's do that's it
is it canceller inch yes yeah then
yeah that should that should solve the
problem right
read it out again tony
um yes that
this committee does not agree
with the statement that there will be no
allocation of maintenance budgets for
payments
right resolution chair sorry
it should say does not agree with the
resolution
right a statement that you're speaking
to it's a resolution
oh okay i i okay
sorry chris okay
all right right then here we go then
sandra just read it out one more time
okay thank you so
we we oh this committee does not agree
with the resolution
of cnr that there will be no
allocation of maintenance budget for
play areas
everybody happy yep
sandra go to the vote please okay thank
you chair
councillor watson four
councillor haines or
councillor bowton or
councillor hawkins or
hans legab ball councillor langford
or penciller manly
for and i'm really really sorry i need
to leave the meeting
um i'm due at work at one o'clock okay
all right thank you thanks
uh councillor inch four councillor
newton
four mr dengue
oh and mr harper
four thank you
that's unanimous thank you so much
for that sure thank you for thank you to
ken james for putting that statement in
chair yes stacey's got her and
up stacy sorry i was just going to say
it might be a convenient time
to vote to extend the meeting past three
hours because
from looking at the agenda yeah you're
not going to get it
shall we extend through one o'clock i
was gonna say the same chair
right uh well we would best do it before
we start anything else because we'd have
to stop
um proposal and secondary
for going over the three hours uh our
proposal
proposed simon newton second
do you want to take the vote sandra
sandra yeah sorry chair i'm having
trouble too i knew
um okay uh councillor watson
councillor haines or councillor bowton
yeah four that's the hawkins
paul pence lookup ball
chancellor langford for penciller wrench
and councillor newton paul
uh mr dengue four and mr harper
thank you chair unanimous lovely thank
you very much
we'll move on i i think i i'm just might
have to just nip out for a minute
because
i need to go to the toilet uh
so we can just get is is sarah
in oh yeah right two minutes
come on come
not done on
i'm back i'm
right okay is everybody gone
a few others have just nipped off for a
moment as well councillor watson
all right okay
i'm still here i'm just making a
sandwich
i'm back i'm back i'm back here
hurt right on
right okay
item 10 then are we ready
goodness well don't much of our
counselor pennington he's not in another
i'm not sure if councillor newton's back
with us yet sure yeah
tony tony you there
well i'm not on the committee i'm i'm
i'm here
yeah that's fine yes i'm i'm here chair
right okay
are you are you still in cole i am sir
right okay okay we'll get on
[Applause]
um item 10 then
i'm working on remote meetings um
oh sarah down to you
yeah okay thank you
so at the ons meeting on the 15th
of december i gave a verbal update on
zoo meetings and homeworking
and members requested further
information which is
covered in this report now so
firstly um carbon cost of holding zoom
meetings so
as a report says it's quite difficult to
put a cost on those meetings
at the moment but the carbon audit
process will cover that and we'll be
able to
offer more information at that time
so secondly i was asked to look at
reduced travel savings for officers and
members
so the table in the report shows the
savings for members
and officers over a given period so
you can see that total savings of 62
from april to december and again
once uh the carbon impact will be
measured
more in the carbon audit
so a questionnaire was sent to members
regarding
virtual meetings and a number of
questions were asked
so we had total a total of 26 responses
and i i guess the the feedback was
similar to staff really and that
the um definitely the the benefits
um there's an acceptance that reduction
in travel is one of the main advantages
of virtual meetings
but that one of the disadvantages is the
social interaction
and it's difficult to understand the
kind of mood and direction of
meetings so members are asked if
given a choice would you prefer virtual
or physical meetings
and there was a slight preference for
virtual meetings
and again members were asked what sort
of meetings would be better suited to a
virtual
environment so there was consensus that
perhaps things like working groups may
be
better suited to virtual meetings
whereas a full council would be better
held
in person and then lastly there was
a question about
when physical meetings start again would
members like them to be
streamed live on youtube and there was
an overwhelming response that 88
of you said yes you would prefer that
at the last meeting i gave some
indication of numbers of zoom meetings
and participants
so there's an updated table in this
report that shows
since march last year there's been a
total of
1264 meetings with just over 8
000 participants
lastly i was asked for some more
information regarding the
staff survey results so staff were asked
a whole host of questions but there was
a
specific set of questions in october 20
with regards
to homeworking they're looking at the
challenges and benefits
so i think as with members really
challenges
with homeworking is social isolation
communication is often a bit more
difficult
but some of the benefits less
distractions
uh easier to have a better work life
balance and
again commuting was seen as a key
benefit
so as a an organization we're currently
considering the accommodation options
going forward
and discussing with managers the
practicalities or otherwise of
increasing or formalizing homeworking
so we will be looking at that further in
the months ahead
so in summary the
environmental benefits of virtual
meetings and homeworking are obvious
but what is less clear is whether public
participation and quality of output is
as high
as it would be in a more normal
environment
our new ways of working will be captured
in the carbon audit process
and will then be able to provide members
and more be
with members with more details on our
carbon usage across the authority
homeworking is more suited to some job
roles than it is to others
as i've already mentioned there's no
overwhelming support for live streaming
of council meetings
into the future given a choice members
show a slight preference for virtual
meetings
and connectivity and i.t issues remain
a barrier to some so i think
largely it's been very very successful
with virtual and home working
but i there are occasional i.t issues
both officers and councillors
acknowledge the lack of social
interaction
is a disadvantage and most seem to favor
an approach where there is a mix between
homeworking and office-based working and
i think
that's what most councils are working
towards some kind of hybrid arrangement
and commuting and reduction in travel is
an advantage recognised by both officers
and members
terrific good reporter has anyone
got any questions for sarah i think that
was a
a damn good report sarah thank you thank
you
yeah i think yeah yeah it's a very good
report
and your hand um big bun do you want me
to put my blue hand up
not now right um yeah just one point
that's been highlighted in
press reports and things is uh home
working
there's a tendency towards merging work
and leisure
um where you eliminate
the whole concept of a separate life
away from work so
it's just that point which needs to be
sort of looked at
and um really um
as one as we go on you know if home
working becomes established
thank you
i know all this is done it is to note
the contents
we note the contents that's uh great job
sarah
councillor has raised his hand all right
i didn't know chris leather was on our
committee but okay
yeah where are you well you're allowed
to speak if you're not on the committee
with your permission on your chair
yeah yeah you are there's others
explained this morning
a lot that's all we're right where are
you anyway
i'm at home same as you at home
um question on the zoom meetings there
on that
chart that shows 1264 zoom meetings i
take it
the majority of these will be officers
to officers
or officers to the leader probably zoom
meetings
and offices to devon county council
officials etc
very few of those attack a small
minority will be actual
counsellor meetings committee meetings
and what kind of a cost would that be
because i haven't got a clue what we pay
for soon
being a member of zoom and what what it
costs us
thanks chair okay
sarah have you got an answer yes
uh yes and no so tom
very kindly provided all the stats for
the zoo meeting so i think
has as he clarified last time that uh
yes it includes some larger meetings but
it also includes one-to-one meetings etc
we also use other facilities here so
internally we may use
teams meetings etc as well so
i don't have to hand the cost of zoom
licenses etcetera but i
could get that for you and clarify that
point you just email them out sarah
all members of the committee yeah
okay anybody else that got anything for
sarah
okay well you know thanks for that sarah
you you're welcome to leave now if you
wish
i'm sure you'd like to leave us
yeah i think everybody would at the
minute but all right thanks for that
sarah anyway
so we'll move on okay
uh what are we on now oh yeah
oh right this is it then this is this is
the big one this is the two-hour job
okay david it's down to you um i think
chris dobbs will just lead off and then
i'll take over from chris
okay
[Music]
chris you're muted
good afternoon everybody good afternoon
chris dobbs muted
uh just a short summary of the qbr3
which is a position of the council's
performance at the end of december 2020.
he's looking at the um our four main
goals
so goal one is our local economy uh the
highlights uh
really the speedy payment of government
grants um again during lockdown two
uh the government wants us to pay grants
as quickly as possible and once again
we prioritize that and have paid grants
quickly to local businesses
um 99.5
of our invoices are paid on time which
is something our accounts team do
again to support local businesses
um the northern brewers center was
granted approval
and actually works well underway now and
due to complete this summer
and for those of you who follow the
harbors and moorings policies finally
been adopted which is good news
uh one disappointment from the economy
was the future high street fund bid
was unsuccessful which is a big
disappointment because it was a very
good bid
and i know chris smaller's team are
trying to work out ways of taking that
forward
we're going to go to which is our local
communities
um janet's team mainly been working with
the health and safety executive
to contact local businesses to make sure
they're curbing 19 secure
housing options team have maintained a
high level of service to make sure they
printed homelessness
and another positive there the full
council tries to do a comprehensive view
an update to the local plan there's a
couple of um
negatives there one is due to uh kobe
particularly
there's been a sharp drop in the
delivery of new homes affordable homes
and that's a knock-on effect as well and
our properties added to the castle tax
database
so a couple of kind of negatives they're
both kirby
uh next slide please tom
moving on to goal three which is um our
environment
some highlights uh we've managed to
maintain our waste of recycling
collections throughout the lockdowns
um our recycling levels have maintained
strongly
uh 55.4 percent due mainly to
increase the glass and cardboard that's
kind of wine on amazon
a particularly good one during the
autumn in october we had um
a container water shot bux mill and it
contained
thousands and thousands of packs of um
incontinence pads
and these containers in two
and janet's team did a really good job
in responding to the crisis
uh coordinated the response and the
cleanup
things were washed down the coast put
together with um
mike from the northern boroughs they
managed to organize some um
volunteers thank you very much from
cliffs and picked everything up so
it was a really good example of our um
emergency planning
working really well but it kind of it
could have been quite a big problem
but they did a really good job
responding
and then again we had the um first phase
of the sea defensive western hillary
completed in december so the lock arm
was added
so a lot of good things on the
environment
we do want to go for our customer facing
stuff
we've had a lot of work coming in during
the last year during lockdowns
and we've managed to maintain high
levels of service across the council
and give you the example of that um
the council tax team have had like a 50
increase in their phone calls coming in
so been a lot of work coming in
and you'll see that the planning team
have had a lot of work and they've
managed to
increase their 10 times um and quite
strange we've actually had reduced
levels of sickness i think that's a
national thing that's been reduced
fitness levels across the country during
this curved crisis
so we've actually been maintaining good
service across the council
a couple of things there on the downside
our turnaround times for local
manchester searches
increased during the autumn due to just
massive work volumes
but still there has been additional
results and that's now being sorted out
and it was obviously a knock on effect
on our cars tax and business rate
collection rates due to covid
so but mostly a really positive quarter
can you move on some please
this slide here is just showing the
impact of coving on our channel shift
we've been shifting channel for a few
years now and really it's kind of really
accelerated that
so during the last year we've seen a a
90
reduction in people coming into
reception we'll see there's been an
increase in phone calls of five percent
and a lot higher increasing phone calls
made but the big change really has been
our emails have gone up to 31
and our website traffic has gone up 34
so our kind of digital
default uh project is being enhanced by
the curvy thing we'll see
a big move towards website and email
traffic
and less kind of phone calls and people
coming to the office
and then the bottom there's just showing
you that our communications
is going very much towards social media
now
um a big increase in traffic on social
media facebook and twitter and instagram
followers
and that's definitely where we're kind
of going in terms of our communication
are there any questions if not i'll hand
over to our head of finance mr hayes
a question from me any questions from
anybody
nobody with their hand up hello david
okay thank you chair well it's been a
long meeting so i'll try get through the
next 74 slides rather quickly
um being ironic there are only three
slides
so what's happening quarter three the
projected surplus has actually improved
by
443 000 um kovid 19
and in particular central government's
response to a threat to an increased
financial volatility for the council
uh what we recommend in the light of the
financial volatility
it's recommended the decision regarding
the utilization of any projected surplus
for 2021 is deferred until the
final accounts are closed and the slide
unfortunately's got a little bit doubled
up there but basically
the key movement since the last quarter
i'll go through the favorable ones first
and then i'll mention the adverse
so staff related savings have increased
by 186 000.
planning income has increased by 154
000. we've had increased covid support
grant from central government
of 83 000 increased income for
increased recycling rates which is cost
share which is the money that we get
from devon county council 73 000
and we've not we have a contingency a
year of reserve every year seventy
thousand well
we're getting towards the end of the
year so obviously we say we don't need
that contingency reserve
and we we've settled the legal case
regarding
uh nap house or conservatively that's
improved the position by 51 000 however
we were awarded costs and should
we receive payment to those costs that
position will actually change even more
to the favorable
um adverse the business rate deficit of
114 000 pounds
um that's actually not so much of that
is actually do with colvid19 actually
quite a lot of that is to do with
actually some big appeals
against business rates that went through
particular apple door shipyard
and we've had reduced car parking income
obviously because of the
uh further lockdowns that have occurred
come up the next slide please tom
so overall we've got favorable variances
which amount to
2.945 million and add those versions of
two and a half million so that's why
we've moved
443 000 favorable variants
but that's after we've already set aside
800 000 pounds to reserves
so actually what i'm actually saying is
in reality we probably underspent 1.2
million
in reality because we've actually put
aside 800 000 reserves and we've moved
more favorably by 443 000 and so much of
this is related to the volatility from
kovid 19 and the
support that we've had from central
government in the main
there's been some other factors
non-covert related or partially
co-related such as
our planning income but it's been a very
very volatile year
so just how volatile has it been next
slide please tom
the on the left-hand side you see two
bar charts um
temporary investments we currently have
at the time of writing this presentation
17 million pound in temporary
investments and actually 11 million
pounds in our current account
this time last year that would have been
11 million and five million and the
reason for such a big difference
is that the governments give us lots of
cash to administrate
to administrate the business support
grants so any one time
we've got a great amount of cash we've
also got a great amount of expenditure
that we've got to process
which is meant it's essentially
difficult to forecast for example cash
flow throughout the year
so i don't want to um go on any more
than this
so the key messages are that the
surplus has increased by 443 thousand
the situation remained volatile as i've
been in this meeting i've seen two
emails are coming with over government
funding that's arrived in today which we
weren't anticipating
and so the recommendation is that we
defer any decision about what to do to
the surplus until we close the accounts
and i think we probably would need to
have a vote on that
sorry david what did you say
sorry david okay i'm just saying that
the recommendation
in the report i believe let me just get
the report in front of me is that
we defer any decision of what we do with
the surplus for this year until the
accounts are closed
given the volatility and we've got zone
just checking the report i think we
might have to make a decision on that
yeah i think that's all we have to do
yeah there's a recommendation
yeah so we recommend to the
recommendation is that members of this
committee recommend to the community and
resources
in light of the continuing financial
uncertainty that any decision regarding
the usage of the 2020-21 surplus
is deferred until the outcome for the
current financial year is known
yeah yeah i propose that
i'll second it
any anybody else
you want the vote taking chair sorry
do you want to take a vote on that oh
yeah
okay councillor watson
oh councillor holmes or
ansel abouten or
ansel hawkins four penciller gab
or pencil langford
four penciller wrench
or pencil newton or
that's unanimous chair okay
next
[Music]
david
hello where were the questions and
answers
they're there on the screen now chair
all right
thank you um
can we all see these questions and
answers
[Music]
you you happy with what's on the screen
at the minute anne
yeah that's fine yeah next strat next
and these are all yours here
well i think now that shelly's got one
but i don't think she needs an answer
really
but ian
yeah happy obviously what it is at the
moment is is the movement of of
responsibility for finances is uh yeah
it's making a mess of everything
yeah next um
it's the same one yeah
happy there
yeah that's fine next page
all yours in yeah the future high
streets
sorry future high streets
sorry future high streets if we've
lost out because the government has made
a a mess up of the um
the waiting for um coastal towns and
rural areas
surely we should be contacting our um
well
they've impacted our bid which is a good
bid
um surely we should be talking to our mp
and trying to resolve some of this
yeah i don't think the reason why we
shouldn't
yeah steve and sean both raise their
hand
oh sorry i'm not i'm not watching i was
looking at the thing
okay i'll take sean first then because
he it looks much happier
i don't we're probably going to say
exactly the same thing we've had
uh detailed feedback on on the bid
and why it didn't make the the grade and
it basically
came down to this benefit cost ratio uh
which was an economic exercise
uh around the va the land value and well
land value uplifts and things like this
all thrown into the bot
i don't i don't think anybody made a
mistake it's just the criteria that they
we were judged against didn't really
suit places like ours and we've made
that representation back to the
government department
so that's done um we were then advised
that um you know what was quality about
our beard or what they thought was very
good quality should i say
and and um we are considering the
suitability for other funding like the
leveling up fund and other things that
are coming forward so
so it we and we're in discussion with
the
um uh the member of parliament about
that so
yeah i think that sort of covers that up
so
so you're already talking to jeffrey cox
so in terms of the leveling up fund
chair which isn't the future high street
fund
the the uh member of parliament will
have eventual
needs to support any bid that we put
forward so it's in our interests
and at the moment i can't i can't
prejudge anything but at the moment the
future high street fund bid would be the
obvious contender for us to be putting
forward for
any leveling up application uh and
the uh jeffrey cox has been in touch
with us about that process
and we'll engage him about the future
high street fund bit he's he's been
keenly interested in it as it progressed
anyway
good thanks sean uh okay then
steve do you want to say anything i
think only only one bit
as sean said he's gonna cover what i was
gonna say the only any bit
to make it clear to members before we
submit a bid to that leveling up
and obviously we will be discussing with
members
uh what you propose to to bid because
there will be as with the future high
streets
the fund application there were
financial implications on the council so
that ended up as a full council
decision so we'd anticipate a similar
process
and as as sean said um it wasn't
anything it was done wrong it's the
methodology in the
the treasury green book is a kind of
long established
government uh methods of evaluating
uh financial and other bids and it is
just
the case that it didn't suit our
particular circumstances
but that is under the process of review
uh by treasury by government so
that way the kind of way that
facilitates
um our types of bids may change not
necessarily to the better we don't know
until we
we see the details but remember sean
said that
um leveling up finding other schemes
available for us to bid for
um going forward i think council
pennington has his hand up
yeah yeah phil pennington i think steve
um you really answer i think the
question
because you've got to come back to full
council again for any new proposal
if you're going to do any underwriting
of uh loans etcetera
is that is as i understand the position
now yeah
excellent thank you chair that's perfect
okay phil
coming next page
back to you ian i looking
yeah it's once again my favorite place
the
the fish stock again as i said and i
understand the reasons that shawn's come
back on it but
we do seem to get two answers one from
um the uh harbour master and one from
sean
um it does cause me some some concern i
have to say
okay do you realize that
this self fashion fresh fish there now
anybody can i was going to say what what
i am pleased to see about as well as
the whole with the fish stock is
something's actually being done now
you have got that fish the the fresh
fish
um it does seem an anatomy anomaly to me
that we are a rural area sorry a coastal
area
and we haven't any wet fish shops any in
the anywhere in the city in the
vicinity well this is good
it looks good as well
okay now i'm i might go in are you
fine with the rest on that page
yeah that's fine next time
and that bit there
yep and there you go shirley you're
right at the bottom
just as an afterthought no it was just
that um
i know it came up last time at how long
the searches were taking so it's really
good that the
extra resources have gone to it and it's
um people have got on top of it that's
great
thank you right i think that's it there
ah anyway forward plan okay for
okay for april we've got the grounds
maintenance thing on and the qbr review
which uh i think you'll all like the new
qbr
how we've set it down um
anybody else would like to put anything
else on that as long as the grounds
maintenance don't take us
three hours that'll be fine
yeah um who's that steve sorry steve
steve dang it
um just in view of the amount of time we
spent on i to make today
um review um the s3 strategy i just feel
that that might be something that we
should
bring to the fore maybe quite soon and
there's a lot of recommendations in
there that actually touched on what the
discussion
covered today yeah so we're look we
could
estimate the extra strategy so chair can
i just clarify something you can
yeah so so when in in that debate there
was a lot of talk about the estuary
strategy
and and what i think people were
referring to was almost like the
voluntary code of conduct for estuary
users
and so the sjo strategy that was
prepared some time ago talked about
commercial activity leisure activity
whole rafter different things
that the voluntary code of conduct was
the one that was uh done in conjunction
with the tortorage estuary forum
where we got all the different user
groups together the um
areas outstanding attributes the
biosphere partnership
um everybody that sort of has an
interest and they came up with that
voluntary code
of conduct for where jet skis should go
for where water skiers should be
going what's a good place for swimming
where launching sites are those sorts of
things
i just wanted to be clear what it is you
wanted to scrutinize there do you want
the estuary strategy
or do you want the user's code of
conduct
i would be looking at the estuary
strategy because we've
talked about that before and also
under the recommendations
it does say that we will continually
review and
see if it's continually fit for for what
we're looking at so i think there's
there's a value in looking at that
7.177.18
i mean i agree the code of conduct is
important and i think there's a lot of
you know educate encourage and enforce
that we could look at in terms of
the jet ski and the other issues and the
harbour
but i do think the the estuary strategy
is something we've touched on a number
of times
and it just feels it lends itself to to
open up that discussion
okay i mean whether we start a small
group
initially just to look at the original
review and recommendations and see if
there's anything that needs to
to be taken forward as a piece of work
but it just felt after today
and you know just some of the other
things that it's going to come more into
the four
so six years since it was written
okay so we'll put that on the forward
plan there
yeah ian
yeah so i was just going to support
completely steve dengate's
proposal on that i've been saying for a
long time
like the fish stock we started started
discussing this from a few years ago
and actually that was pulled away from
the uh ons committee
um and that was when we had that the
real problems with the fish stock
also the harbor as well but it's also is
looking very much
not so much of the code of practice but
how the estras used and that's
talked about it today of how you use it
for tourism and for leisure as well
so there's an element there this is
quite important and there could be as
you say
additional income we can generate from
that i think those are things we really
should be looking at
okay so you'd like that to do that to go
on the forward plan as well
you you're okay with that yeah more
more than happy with that i think that's
something we should be looking at
okay that's fine right peter aims
yeah thank you jerry i support that that
we should re
revisit yesterday's strategy
particularly as as
far as i can recollect it encourages
water sports on the estuary
so we need to look at that and look in
terms of a balance
to be achieved okay
tony thank you chair yes
well we've got some thing done about
empty homes and a football house in
there in the
uh forward plan to come up but um
having looked at the news and reports of
the news
lately especially in cornwall and things
like that that they have had
lots of landlords now selling up their
um
rented accommodation for various reasons
i wonder if we could just keep our eye
on the um
homelessness in and and uh and the
amounts of people that were putting up
in our
hotels and in other places because i
feel that uh
coming out of this pandemic now as we
are well hopefully we are
um i think that's one thing that might
uh uh we're going to drop off for sort
of an edge of a cliff
and we'll get lots and lots of people
wanting homes and there's not going to
be enough around
and i'm very very um worried about this
we've seen on social media lately i have
anyway
that people requesting and seeking out
homes
i think there was one case on the news
where
they said that they were offering 300
pounds more
if they could get a home if they could
get this house
and you know it's i think it's just
gonna get worse i don't know if we can
put that somewhere
um to perhaps so come up
every every time we have a meeting every
couple of months anyway now
um just to see how we're going on that
yeah because it does
it does cost us a lot of money doesn't
it it does cost us a lot of money
and steve s wants to come in he's going
to tell us it don't cost us anything now
i'm not going to say anything about
costs i'll leave that to
david no all i was going to say is
obviously something we're aware of
and councillor james is a committee
member and obviously
councillor james put a notice emotion
about housing
to full council some time ago and uh
john walters also called give a an
update
to members of leadership a couple of
weeks ago about the work that's
started on looking at a wider piece of
work around housing and housing strategy
and you know the next phase is to set up
a workshop so
critical data and information um
that council lynch has referred to is
obviously key to pulling together
what we want to do so there some of the
that
some of those bits of information will
be collated as part of developing that
strategy
right thanks steve anybody else
got anything to say
no well thank you all for
for participating in this meeting this
has been the best meeting we've had in
years
you know i'm probably the longest um but
yeah it's
it's been really good and thank you to
everybody for coming all the officers
and sitting there nice and gently
and and looking really interested
um and especially stacy looking really
interested
um and anyway i'm really appreciate what
you've done today
okay thank